Unfortunately, like I hate the anti-Semitic
attacks against Hasan. >> Is he allowed to say that? Is
was he allowed Is he allowed to say that? I don't know if he's
allowed to say that. You picked a champion that has no principles,
that has no beliefs, and you get what you deserve, okay? Destiny
is a despicable person who's been credibly accused of harassment,
revenge, and various other misdeeds by four separate women. You
get a champion that totally kneels and totally admits that you've
all been histrionic for months and years.
Okay, so this is the This is the Tim Miller conversation. We'll
basically jump right into it, okay? The first part is just they
They're agreeing that Trump sucks. All right, we don't have to
watch any of that part. That part sucks. This part is pretty
good. Mostly because I just get to laugh that I was totally
Everything Everything I've been saying, 100% correct. Destiny
has come to the light. He has agreed He's He's totally incorrect.
You can't be like unhinged towards Hasan. You can't say never
talk to him. You can't go and tell all these people never talk
to him. Don't Don't associate. Don't Don't associate yourself
cuz he's terrible. He doesn't love democracy. He hates democracy.
Anti-liberal, right? You can't do that. I just I take a victory
lap right off the bat, okay?
Because I was correct. And the funny thing that we'll keep in
mind as we go through this, the very funny thing, I probably
agree with NotSoErudite in the way you have to approach conversations
and you can only change people's minds slowly over time, okay?
When she tells Destiny that, he brutally slaps her down. He brutally
just destroys her, okay? No holds barred. But then Tim will say
a lot of the same things that NotSoErudite would say and just
watch Destiny's response to those things when Tim's doing it,
right? Erudite, of course, eventually did break and decide to
adopt Destiny's opinion, but it's funny cuz he browbeat her out
of the opinion that Tim has basically on platforming and and
talking to people. Then Destiny's just going to slowly come back
around to it after he got not so erudite and Wick to sort of
debase themselves on the same topic. It's just very, very funny,
man. Dude, the Bullwark people are crazy.
This is wild.
Uh warning to Destiny and Hasan fans from the mod team. Please
respect this subreddit and don't use this as an ideological battleground
in a forum to air your grievances against each other. From my
experience, Destiny fans are just as cultish, toxic, and downright
obnoxious, if not vastly more so, than the Hasan fans. Destiny
is a despicable person who's been credibly accused of harassment,
revenge, and various other misdeeds by four separate women. He's
a Trump-like figure in many in many ways, I think is what it
means to say. Anyways, all right. This is pinned on their subreddit,
by the way.
So, any pro-Destiny videos or pro-Destiny content, unless it's
done with a Bullwark pundit, will be immediately deleted and
the user potentially banned. Even the cool Decoding the Guru's
posts, Chris and Matt, have stopped interacting with Destiny
since these allegations came to light. So, maybe not the best
decision by Tim to do a live stream with him, but anyways, this
is a warning to users here about posting other
content. Please respect this subreddit and go pick your battles
elsewhere.
Well, that's crazy.
Is he thing in the comments are 100%
Um Oh, there there was seething in the comments. Well, that's
funny. I don't think it was wrong for Tim Miller to have this
conversation.
I think Basically, this conversation leads to people going, "Hey
Tim, did you know these things about Destiny?" And Tim can go,
"Oh, I didn't know that." And then he can decide between, "Well,
I want to talk to Destiny about this." or "I don't want to talk
to Destiny about this." You guys just published another article,
um or the Bullwark did about uh Hasan I think this morning. And
this fixation on like Hasan says edgy things. He said this thing
about uh Crenshaw. He said this edgy thing about America deserves
a 9/11. I think that that's it's a mistake when the fixation
is on just edgy stuff, because I think that you can overlook
edgy comments. I would say this is somebody that makes edgy comments,
right? But what I would wish that people would do is fixate more
like, okay, forget the But when I do edgy stuff, like record
people's with other consent, that's like something you would
look past. But when Hassan says America deserved 9/11, you actually
have to understand that's fundamental to his like I hate America,
America must perish at all costs ideology.
Okay. Edgy comment, okay. What is the underlying ideology? And
when you look at a lot of these types, Hassan for sure, but like
the socialist movement I think in the far far left in general
in the United States, these people are not ideologically aligned
with the Democratic Party. And they've basically said, not basically,
they have said as much multiple multiple multiple times. And
there's like superficial
um kind of layover sometimes, but like So this is going to very
quickly become not about Hassan, it's going to become about like
the D program people, right? That's where they they constantly
try to push Hassan in that direction, even though Hassan from
what I can tell does try to differentiate himself from those
people, right? Does have fights with those people. It seems like
he's in his own camp like in the middle of these two groups.
Pretty obviously. When you actually try to ca- Sorry, the the
two groups being like actual Marxist-Leninists, actual like tankies
who are trying to who who do want a revolution, violent or otherwise,
to abolish private property, right? He seems to actually separate
himself from those people quite
quite starkly.
There's maybe one or two comments where he's like, "Wow, when
you start the vanguard party and get the revolution going, I'm
right there with you, There's one comment like that. Where Okay,
that's like I guess so, but are we going to pretend that that
undoes the hours and hours and hours of stumping for candidates,
of talking about electoralism, talking about politics? Are we
going to pretend it undoes all of the rest of the
Feels kind of goofy. cash it out into some kind of policy, it's
never there.
you know, like like I've seen people on the far left Jank will
attack the Affordable Care Act because he says that it's part
of the um they call it a corporate release of album all the time
or you've got people on the far left will play into it poll or
social issues until those are brought up in opposition to some
socialist idea and then you know you know I've seen there are
videos of Hasan screaming about like social policy doesn't matter
it's totally irrelevant this is just oh rainbow capitalism they're
just throwing things in front of you to try to distract you from
the class issues and then yeah basically what what I'm trying
to say is that like it's not just that they're a little bit further
left there's like a substantial
ideological disagreement where their goal is to destroy the Democratic
Party literally and to co-opt and be subversive while trying
to get people on the left to yeah appeal to them yeah.
Dude Tim's like barely listening. Tim's like dude can we just
chill for like two
you like actually
Tim tapped out. >> and to co-opt and be subversive while
trying to get people on the left to yeah appeal to them yeah.
I have a lot of thoughts. Oh that's brutal.
That's brutal. Tim Tim's like done listening before Destiny's
quite finished. Yeah yeah yeah yeah so You see him back off there
to try to make it sound like >> subversive while trying
to get people on the left to yeah appeal to them yeah. I have
a lot of thoughts on it. >> Go for it. And so we'll have
like I want to make sure that let's listen the full
the full view of them is shared so we can go a little long whatever
I'm I'm A whole bunch of just generic points he made there that
may or may not apply to some some cases. I guess the rainbow
capitalism point that doesn't sound like a point to me going
hey Google doesn't really care about gay people they're just
doing this because they think that gets them more more money.
Well considering that Google Facebook all these the same arguments
you made Destiny that they totally knelt to Trump the second
he came into power it seems like that was correct.
They all dropped those those programs everything like that totally
as soon as Trump came into power. Part of it like what you're
doing like you have a ongoing running like almost kind of global
college dorm room fight happening with with with Hasan like over
a decade, right? Which is you're trying to convince people the
values of liberalism. He's trying to convince people the values
of democratic socialism or left-wing authoritarianism, whatever
he whatever he would end up landing, yeah.
Dude, authoritarian socialism. Try to convince people the values
of authoritarian socialism. How is he doing that? By constantly
trying to participate in the democratic process?
That's how he's doing it? Feels like there's got to be easier
ways, no? I kind of cut that off. >> And with with with
Hasan like over a decade, right? Which is you're trying to convince
>> I love that Tim did this. He immediately came in and
went, "I'm aware that you and Hasan have this like total like
blood feud going on. So like I get that. And do you notice I
feel like that recalibrates the conversation almost immediately?
That Destiny was getting ready a little bit to go in that direction
and make the argument. And now he's kind of realized, does Tim
know? Well, I mean
he's saying it, no?
the values of liberalism. He's trying to convince people the
values of democratic socialism or left-wing authoritarianism,
whatever he whatever he would end up landing, yeah. He would
call it left the former, but it might really be the And I think
that's an important debate to have and obviously I'm on your
side with that, right? Um you know, I'm maybe not on every specific
sub issue, um but like as far as >> Directionally. Say
directionally, Tim. >> trajectory is concerned. And I've
criticized Hasan a bunch over the past couple months, including
in person when I talked about him. Um and so like I think we
can like that's one thing and we can talk about that. The other
thing is the question of like how the left interacts with partisan
politics. Okay? And in particular, I'm focused right now on how
the anti-war left intersects with par- partisan politics more
so than like the socialist left cuz in some ways That's interesting,
anti-war left. That's a good way of putting it, right? Cuz realistically,
I think Tim's criticism is this. This
is the worst possible way you could attack Hasan now. There's
no excuse for putting political tribalism before safety or for
overlooking hatred to generate some likes online or for failing
to act against the surge of anti-Semitism spread by the Hasan
Pikers of the world and normalized by too many on the Democratic
side. We're all for a big tent, but the Democratic Party needs
to draw a line in the sand. Hasan [__] and his fellow
haters belong on the other side. Core thesis, Hasan is the same
as Nick Fuentes, Candace Owens, Tucker Carlson. Hasan needs to
be excised from the Democratic Party and should not be spoken
to by any politicians. So, this specific article, this specific
strategy of trying to outflank Hasan is the worst possible option
you could go for. He might even agree that Hasan shouldn't be
platformed. He might even agree that Hasan is like dangerous
or something. He could agree with those things, but this specific
issue is the worst possible issue to go at him over. Right? By
the way, Destiny doesn't agree with this. He probably does agree
with it in the conversation, but he would totally disagree in
reality and say, "No, no, no, no, no. Hasan is actually very
anti-Semitic. It's actually very critical that you decry him
for
Right? Otherwise, I don't know how
I don't know what all the past like 2 years have been about if
if not that. So, it's good that Tim's talking about the anti-war
left. He's saying you're off not the socialist. The you're off
the anti-war left. There are a bunch of people who aren't tankies
who are hearing you go after Hasan over Israel and they're like,
"Dude, we have watched what's going on with Israel. How the [__]
are you taking somebody else's side on this? How the [__]
are you taking Israel's side on this? Get the [__]
out of here, right?" They overlap in some ways that they they
don't.
and I just I I I think that the Democratic Party has really hurt
its brand over the past decade by letting Trump take the mantle
of being the anti-war person. And obviously that was obviously
you and I saw through that. Some of the far-left streamers did
not see through that. We should dunk on them and call them stupid.
In the in the world of streaming, right? That is fine. But like
that doesn't change the fact that it happened. Like it happened.
You know, and there's a significant chunk of the population some
of them left some of them are are consuming manosphere podcasts,
some of them are not really political, they just aren't a fan
of wars, think it's stupid how much money we've been spending
in the Middle East, don't want themselves or their kid to go
to war, and like the fact that Trump said that was appealing
to them and the Democrats like seemed like the party of whatever
the blob. And Well, and I mean, he was the guy that came out
and criticized the Iraq War. That that was the unique thing that
made him different than the Republican candidates. Up until that
point it was anathema in the Republican Party to criticize Bush
or the Iraq War for the Iraq War. If nothing else, that was hey,
we got revenge for 9/11. That is why it was anathema to criticize
the Iraq War in the Republican Party. Trump broke that, right?
Very much in a similar way to right now. It's like the same moment
playing out again, right?
That you can't really defend Israel on this on the Gaza stuff,
on Lebanon, on Syria, on everything. You can't defend Israel,
right? But it's been anathema to point this out in the Democratic
Party. That is about to change. That is about to make a major
major change.
And I think that that was a branding mistake in retrospect. Like
obviously. And right now in this moment in April of 2026, like
it's the Democrats' best chance to like recapture that they are
party against stupid wars, right? That doesn't mean that they're
isolationist or whatever, but like we are the party against stupid
wars. It was Bush that sent us to Iraq and Afghanistan. It's
Trump that started this Iran war. you are paying more at the
pump right now, it is because of Trump and because of his friends
in the Middle East, MBS, and BB, and the other corrupt buddies
that he's doing deals with. Like they it's their fault. Yeah,
MBS has been lobbying him constantly. MBS has been spending all
of his time lobbying him for this. MBS has been sharing intelligence
from the infamous Saudi intelligence service with Trump trying
to get him to go and strike Iran. For sure. Yeah, it's all it's
all, you know, let's put MBS and BB in the same camp. 100% man.
Fault. >> fault. We're on the other side. If you put us
back in charge, we're not going to do this. They did they tricked
you. You were fooled. I'm sorry. None of that is to say that
MBS wouldn't be behind
like what happened there.
MBS surely hates Iran. Surely, right? But it's just that he was
not Even if he wanted the war, he wasn't the person lobbying
for it constantly.
Ari, I'm we're doing my best to win you back over. Like I just
think that it's like really >> not contributing intelligence
and a whole bunch of other [__] okay?
Uh MBS love Yeah, no no no. Obviously MBS MBS has no concern
in his mind
about anything ideological. MBS is not an ideological creature.
MBS's ideology is money. That's MBS's ideology, okay? Money,
business. I want money and business. I want more business in
Saudi Arabia. I want money. I want money. I want money. He wants
the status quo to be happening so that he can continue to invest
continue to build his empire, right? That's what he wants. Really
important that This war is totally antithetical to that concept.
>> in charge, we're not going to do this. They did they
tricked you. You were fooled. I'm sorry. I'm we're doing my best
to win you back over. Like I just think that it's like really
important that the the the Democrats recapture this posture right
now. Mhm. And so like for me, the Hassan discourse got wrapped
up in that. Where I was like, I just thought it was really stupid
strategically.
Like, whether you're putting on your Democratic Party hat, or
your centrist hat, or your liberal democracy hat, to be like,
"Right now, I'm going to pick the fight with the anti-war left."
Now, if you're more precise about what you're criticizing Hasan
on, okay, but like this I'm trying to dep- you know, all of this
stuff, you know, letting, you know, the Insider blog in DC, which
is a Republican cutout, like dominate the discourse. And like,
you know, by by asking
John Ossoff a question here about what he thinks about Hasan.
Like, this is stupid. I got I got into this discourse by starting
by posting on Twitter, "Democrats should tell any interest group
that wants to know their opinion on Hasan to eat [__]
right now." Because the only groups that are trying to do it
right now are trying to do it to run cover for
uh you know, the people that are in favor of this war. And Thank
you, Tim. Thank you. This face, yeah. Obviously, the only reason
you're trying to criticize Hasan right now, the only reason you're
trying to seize on this opportunity, is because you're in favor
of this war. You're trying to run cover for this war. You'd be
to not do this. And it's so funny cuz obviously, Destiny's been
doing a ton of criticism of Hasan over this stuff, right? And
yes, he is describing Destiny perfectly. But, let's watch Destiny's
response. Surely, Destiny has to go, "No, no, no, no, no, that's
crazy. That just you don't support this war just because you're
like calling out Hasan." Surely, he'll say that. >> it,
anyway. So, like that was the beginning of this, and then it
spirals into a bunch of other stuff. And so,
I have more thoughts on how Democrats should engage with the
left, but like those are my two main things. Okay. Well, he's
actually Tim is going to pause and give Destiny time to respond.
Let's go. >> at the start. Sure. So, on the second thing,
um I 1 trillion percent agree. Uh I'm going to look back to my
early
Dude, what? Yeah, it is really Dude, it is actually Yeah, going
after Hasan on this on this war stuff. That's so stupid. I 1
trillion percent agree. There's no way. unto each right now cuz
the only groups If you're criticizing Hasan right now, it's only
being used to run cover for this war. And if you are criticizing
Hasan, you need to eat [__] People need to tell you
to eat [__] And Destiny goes, "Oh, on that part,
I 100% I I 1 trillion percent agree, man.
No shot." that are trying to do it right now are trying to do
it to run cover for you know, the people that are in favor of
this war. And so, anyway, So, like that was the beginning of
this and then Destiny does a bunch of other stuff. And so, I
more thoughts on on how Democrats should engage with the left,
but like those are my two main Yeah, that was the point. Okay,
that was the point. On point two, I 1 trillion percent agree.
Uh no, you don't. And that was literally your point the whole
time. So, it's very concerning to me that you just totally cocked
you totally knelt to Tim. Well, it's not actually concerning,
right? It's actually great. Destiny admitting he was wrong, Destiny
totally falling back from all the [__] he's been
posting, all the [__] he's been saying. It's actually
a total win for everybody who I guess just wants
you know, Israel not to get away with the the [__]
they're doing in Lebanon, in in Iran, in Syria, in
Gaza. Sorry, I was like in Israel. I was going to say in Gaza.
Right? If you if you're on that side, you don't want Israel getting
away with it. It's nice when people who are major figureheads
for that side totally kneel.
But it's also kind of weird given the whole Soy Boy convo, given
everything that's been going on, but I just wanted to make clear.
Hey, just on the second thing, I 1 trillion percent agree. I'm
going to look back to my earlier kind of media model for why
I think unfortunately, like I hate the anti-Semitic
attacks against Hasan. I I do actually think that Dude, no. My
brain. My brain. My brain. How do I save it? How do I save my
brain? It's a psychic attack. Again. What? What?
There's no way. There's no I'm going to look back to my earlier
kind of media model for why I think unfortunately, like I hate
the anti-Semitic
attacks against Hasan. I I do actually think that him and a lot
of people on the left, him especially, are anti-Semitic. But,
um
I care about social stuff, but I think there's way, way, way
more problematic things than anti-Semitism.
Um Oh, this is what happens, by the way. Hey, hey, Israel. Hey,
Israel shills. You picked a champion that has no principles,
that has no beliefs, and you get what you deserve, okay? You
get a champion that totally kneels and totally admits that you've
all been histrionic for months and years. That's what you get
when you pick this champion. Get
Okay? So awesome. I You love to see it. You love to see it. Oh,
it feels good, okay? It feels so good. Doesn't it feel good?
Doesn't it feel good?
Oh my god. >> Especially cuz Israel is [__]
it all up now anyway, so my sympathies are very low at the moment,
but the the issues are these like Israel is [__]
it all up, and I think I should say that Hasan has definitely
said some anti-Semitic stuff, including as recently as recently,
but as recently as like last week. But, um he also I I think
he's feeling the pressure on this, and this goes to like a third
point I want to get to eventually, which is like he's he's modulated
his rhetoric on that in a way that's potentially useful. But,
anyway, you might think it's potentially un- un-useful because
I was Oh, Hasan's actually like coming around on this. Hasan's
actually being a little bit better on this recently. Not that
you'd agree. They He definitely
It's It's all dog whistles, but not but not even like quiet dog
whistle. Like, when you're screaming at somebody calling them
a banging pig and all the the inbred comments or whatever. A
banging pig. Dude, banging for blood, calling authoritarians
hogs, which he's done for every group. It's not even a good
My god. >> everything else. Like, these are they're usually
hitting on certain anti-Semitic tropes, like they need to go
back to Brooklyn, they don't belong there, stuff like What?
What did the banging pig thing have to do with going back to
Brooklyn? Not even remotely coherent arguments. Didn't he prepare
for this?
What is he doing instead of preparing for this? I thought he
prepared for this. This is not coherent at all. >> This
but regardless of that, I think the reason why the discourse
carries is because the have you know as has been noticed through
the last 2000 years whatever human history they're very good
at doing their media messaging right? You've got your Dude, what?
Wait, what?
Is he allowed to say that? Is was he allowed is he allowed to
say that? I don't know if he's allowed to say that. Dude, what?
Your APAC people you've got
I don't know if the Southern Poverty Law Center or the the the
name of the No, it's not them. There's another group that is
on Twitter that like calls out like anti-Semitic people or whatever.
Like they're very Yeah, the ADL that's what I'm thinking of.
Yeah. They're very good at their vertical integration and everything.
They label somebody you know like this guy's anti-Semitic here's
why and then that message like resonates within the entire tuning
fork of kind of the
I I guess like interest And And Dessie has nothing to do with
that. And Dessie couldn't you couldn't possibly argue Dessie
has anything to do with that. And the attacks on Hassan there,
right? You couldn't Oh, no. Wait, you couldn't possibly agree
on that. structure >> So, you couldn't possibly have anything
to do with that. You don't even know what that's about. I don't
even know the guy who's like my best friend who set that whole
thing up. I don't know anything about this, guys. >> too
much like a Nazi right now, okay, but those Oh, they were like
pestering Dan to get back into snarking Kassad. I don't know
what but like they're they're very good at like messaging on
these types of issues. >> You're not a Nazi to be clear.
>> was not I'm not I'm trying not to go on to I'm trying
very hard to not go on Nazi platforms and I've not watched all
of your videos. all eight hours of your streams every day. >> I promise
I'm not a Nazi, okay? Of course if I was a Nazi I would say exactly
that, right? You know, I'm just kidding. I'm not. But they're
they're very good at messaging on this thing in a very unified
way which I think is why this is what's carrying through the
strongest. But the other type of messaging like I agree I scream
again I agree so much that Democrats aren't good Sorry. unbelievable.
That is Oh, the funny thing about this with his phone going off
is when they start the convo Tim goes oh, yeah, something got
canceled on me, so I got time for this now."
And it's like, bro, were you going to go on MS now with your
phone not silenced?
What the heck? That is such an amateur >> going to What
the heck, man? That's a streamer mistake, so you're coming to
our world, okay? It It happens, you
Keep going. Um that the the reason why the Democrats can't stake
out a position on this is because right now the anti-war rhetoric,
I think, is completely captured by that right-wing tuning fork
and your far left tuning fork. And to stake out like a decently
nuanced position on the center left would Oh, no.
Is this just a Is this just a different flavor of Actually, if
you If you agree about Israel, the anti-Semites win, and we can't
let that happen. There's no way, right? There's no way. Oh, if
you let this If you let this happen, then the anti-Semites win.
No shot. Oh, also, when he says like, "Oh, the ADL has this whole
thing set up, the tuning fork and stuff."
I remember there was a clip, and I think I think we got it here,
of basically this exact thing happening where people where Dan
was hanging out with Mouton and Destiny, and they're trying to
get They're trying to like, you know, talk a little bit about
Dan. Be like, "Why isn't Dan doing this?" >> Miller are
never ever ever coming across episodes of the deep of the deep
program or whatever. That's what I'm saying. >> No, unless
it's on literally like CNN. >> Somebody else So yeah, somebody
else has to bring it up, yeah. Which is why Dan could be useful
right now. Exactly. People who do not know who that is. What?
Why isn't Dan doing this? Why isn't Dan going and getting all
of these talking points about Hasan out there? What the [__]
is Dan doing? And then Dan did come on, and they were trying
to go over some stuff. It's very funny, okay? It's very very
very funny.
But anyway, when you talk about the Hasan talking points and
how that resonates with the ADL, the I guess the Twitter tuning
fork, right? That's exactly who they wanted to do, or who they
wanted to do it to.
Do it with, god damn it. Dan. Who is on?
Good enough. Good enough. That's enough for the stream, okay?
would require our resonating tuning fork to where, my god, there
are Yeah, I um
I have like a really bad headache, so we're doing our best, okay?
I'm doing my best. Headache is killing me right now. center left
your far left tuning fork and to stake out like a decently nuanced
position on the center left would require our resonating tuning
fork to where, my god, there are so many criticisms that you
could give of Israel. There are so many criticisms you could
give of American foreign policy.
You give me a criticism of Israel right now? What's the criticism?
Give me a crit- Give me a critique of something Israel's done.
Uh you know, in in general, but there is no democratic
apparatus to message any of those criticisms through. So, like,
I don't know if you've ever been in an area where, uh you know,
coming from gaming,
If I knew that my message was going to be amplified by Democrats,
right? If I criticize Israel, I want to know that my message
is going to be amplified by other Democrats. And I don't think
that that's reasonable right now. There's not even There's no
There's no mechanism. What am I supposed to do? Just Just tweet
something on principle? Get out of here. Girls say dumb stuff
online in the streamer world, but when you criticize a woman
in the gaming world, you got to be really careful cuz just because
it's ni-
There's no way. There's no He did not just say this.
Who have you been careful criticizing? What woman around you
have you been really careful criticizing?
I'm so Dude, there's no way that he's just going to go on here
and lie this blatantly the whole time. Dude.
Around me, I've I've Listen, I'm really specialized in not criticizing
women to the degree that you should, okay? When I called the
person suing me for me sending of her to somebody without her
consent, when I talked about her, I call her a gold digging a
clout that she's trying to her way up the streamer ladder. That's
how I talk about her. I have to be very careful about this. Wow.
90% men or whatever. There's a lot of stuff. So, I have to be
careful because I know if I start attacking somebody on a thing,
like there's there's a lot of stuff. Brother, anytime you have
an argument with a woman, all of your chat implies they have
mental illness
Because of memes you put forward. Going to be 400 Twitter men.
Not even memes, because of serious Yeah, sincere arguments you
put forward about this. Chance like, oh, this this girl streamer
He's got maybe the most space on the internet. How in the world
Well, sorry, maybe not on the internet. In this sphere of the
internet. I don't even think that's a question, is it? It's the
most place by far in the like center-left to left-wing sphere
of the internet. It's not even close.
Like you have to go over to the right-wing. You have to go over
to like Andrew Tate who or Andrew Wilson. You have to go see
the arguments over there to even talk about these issues. Or
said a thing that this is really dumb. And a whole bunch of people
come out like, yeah, this stupid this dumb. Why shouting? He's
like, okay, well, hold on. Jesus, not like that. Calm down. Jesus,
guys. And I think with the
Oh, this whole thing is meant to be again, like I said, a targeted
psychic
You wouldn't You wouldn't want to do that. You wouldn't want
to say those things, man. Uh-oh. No, you don't get it, guys.
When he says those things, they're just real. They're just true.
Okay? That's the difference. They're real and true when he says
them. They're just totally like gross and misogynistic when other
people say them. Anti-war messaging, it's an it's an issue that
has been so captured by both sides. It feels really uncomfortable
to step in and be like, yeah, you're right. I think we should
be anti-helping Israel in the war. And they're like, that's great.
So, we're going to abolish the state tomorrow, right? And then
yeah. That's That's literally not the conversation. Not even
remotely. The hyperbole, the attempted hyperbole is so
What is this based on? The fact that Hassad wants one person,
one vote in Israel eventually?
I Again, maybe you have to go and talk to Hassad about it. I
assume if you got asked the question, he would go, "Well, yeah,
you can't just like take down all the walls tomorrow without
any conversations happening." Like that would go badly.
And by the way, he's going to keep running this out. This idea
that people are like, "Oh, actually,
Israel has to be abolished tomorrow. It's the only way." No,
the argument is stop funding Israel. Stop funding them. Stop
giving them a security guarantee. No more qualitative military
edge. These kinds of things. A lot of people are grading on you
that that that's do saying anti-Semitic stuff. I This is my thing
on the anti-Semitism discourse. I've talked about anti-Semitism
a lot on the podcast. I'm genuinely concerned about it. >> Yeah.
I I also think that um that like this war and the way that they've
argued for it is doing more to propagate anti-Semitism than almost
anything. Like I I just I don't under and and
There's no way he could let that go. There's no way he could
let that go. I I said this. I was told by D Ears, "There's no
excuse for anti-Semitism. There's never an excuse for anti-Semitism."
Surely, Destiny, champion of Israel, would never allow that to
get through, right? The idea that Israel's actually causing anti-Semitism
in the world? Surely not. That's an insane thing to say, Tim.
I've been told it's an insane thing to say. It's obviously true,
but I've been told it's an insane thing to say. that
that like this war and the way that they've argued for it is
doing more to propagate anti-Semitism than almost anything. Like
I I just I don't under and and and I and I and there is almost
no acceptance of that among the people that are like big Israel
supporters. And because they refuse to accept that. And I'm like
I'm Well, as of yesterday, Destiny is no longer a big Israel
supporter, so he will agree with him entirely, right? >> I
conflating criticizing criticizing Israel right now when they
have
at some level been involved in encouraging us into this war.
I'm not trying to say that it was like they did it, so you wouldn't
have ever done it without them, but like it was they were a big
part of getting us in this war and they're our partner in this
war and it's the stupidest [__] war imaginable. It's
going to be a total disaster. It might empower Iran Iran in the
end and and people are paying more. Everyone's lives are going
to be made worse. Nobody understands why we're doing it. And
so it's like I don't think it's irrational for a regular person
who wakes up one day and looks at their the price of their gas
tank and it went up 20 bucks and they're like, "Why is this happening?
I haven't been following the news. Why is this happening again?"
And then people are like, "Well, Iran had some nuclear missile
it's a ballistic missiles and they and they're they had too many
ships and Trump decided he wanted to bomb them." And it's like
and then another person says, "Oh, no, he did it for There's
literally oh, dude. Who's Destiny watching that's talking about
before 47 years? Who's he Who could he possibly be watching there
where you learned that one from? I
Dude, it's actually crazy that he is
biting the bullet on all of this. He's not saying anything back
to Tim. What
Dude, I it's so delicious watching this
again, like I said earlier, okay? You if you strap your wagon
if you if you hitch your wagon to somebody with no principles
who doesn't believe in anything, who doesn't stand for anything,
then when they desert you in your moment of need, you cannot
be shocked at all. You can't be shocked even a little bit. And
it's just it's actually funny watching it happen to all the people
who believe that this guy really had some principled tie to Israel,
some principled tie to anything.
It's a very funny to watch, okay? I'm it's like Schadenfreude
for a bunch of people who aren't Destiny
perpetrated by Destiny.
Great. It's great for Israel. And it's like I don't know, man.
I'm just sorry. One argument just seems pretty compelling because
the the people who are making the case for this war have not
made a very compelling case for why it is, and it's going to
cause a lot of harm. So, I I just think that like I'm frustrated
like that is frustrating in this moment that like um that that
is the position that we're in, but that is just the position
that we're in. And so, I think that the Democrats
I I think because for a lot of for good instincts, for the reasons
you just laid out, don't want to be loud as loud and clear-eyed
as they could be on this because they they're worried about that.
Like they're worried about having And And it's just like, man,
this is the thing. Successful
There's only two parties in the country. Like if you become the
president, you had anti-Semites who voted for you, you had homophobes
who voted for you, you had bigots who voted for you. It's just
like, if you get 70 million votes, like that's just the nature
of it, right? And so, I So, I'm not saying the Democrats should
say or do anything anti-Semitic, but they need to be a hundred
times more passionate in opposing this war that's going to people's
lives than they need to be in fighting internal
internecine fights right now. And and you you as a streamer have
a different
obligation and job. It's Dude, Tim is saying all the things that
have been getting said by everybody adjacent to Hasan. He's literally
just copying the Hasan rhetoric. And Destiny has to sit here
because he wants to bridge with Tim. He has to sit here and agree
with everything Tim says.
I truly believe Hasan's going to watch this conversation and
like laugh his ass off. I think so. I think you basically have
to.
It's so funny. I'm then a Democratic
Um and so, and you're on here for 8 hours. You can fight as many
internecine fights as you want. But like the Demo- I just feel
like the Democratic establishment needs to like get the credibility
of being anti this war as clearly and passionately as possible.
I'll help them with the echo
I might as well help them with the echo chamber. I might as well
I don't know. I think there are plenty of people out there that
would help elevate really passionate anti-war voices right now
on the Democratic Party and you know, a couple of them are doing
okay. Ruben Gallego is doing pretty good. Chris Murphy. But it
just it's missing right now. Of the like think of the 2028ers.
If you thought about the potential 2028ers, who has been like
the most vocal and clear and passionate in opposing this war
right now? I can't think of anybody. It's hard to think about
who would be the fit for that. And I think that's a huge mistake.
Gavin Newsom? Oh, wait. Oh, wait.
Cuz I love I love that Hassan specifically has pointed out how
Gavin Newsom flip-flopped and how he was totally correct in what
he said that you can't trust Gavin Newsom. He's not going to
commit a vote to him, right? And Hassan was totally correct on
that. He did flip-flop. He has no principles. That's that's just
oh.
Could you imagine?
Could you imagine if I pre-watched this and knew that Destiny
was going to bring that up and sort of just sort of like shake
his head and go, "Yeah, Gavin Newsom even he felt
I do agree with you um that we need that more positive position
out there of somebody saying it. Um I I think one of my there's
two things here. So, one is my issue is just you can stake that
Or not. I Or not. I Like I said, I have a headache. I'm pretty
sure they bring up Gavin Newsom and they laugh about how he felt
though. >> position out without trying to appeal to or
or or I I guess like curry favor with people on the I would say
on the far left whose positions, you know, might be superficially
similar, but they're not, you know? Like if you had a friend
that came into your house and your other friend is like, "That
guy's going to rob from you." You're like, "What do you mean?"
He's like, "He's black. He All black people steal." It's like,
"Okay, whatever." If he does end up robbing you, I don't think
you would say, "Oh man, like do you have a really good point,
actually? Racism is actually really good. Damn, I should Oh,
yeah, this is exactly the point that I've been making over and
over again. That it literally isn't supporting communism to go
to disavow Israel. But that's the argument people have been making.
Essentially like if you support disavowing Israel, you're a communist.
Only communists have been disavowing Israel. It's like dude,
they're totally disconnected. This guy's been watching my streams.
Let's Oh, should just assume it. Right. And then, you know, you
if you >> Oh, what is he saying? He is saying that like
He is saying, what he's trying to argue is
If you criticize Hasan, or sorry, if you if you criticize Israel
and Hasan celebrates, that doesn't mean Hasan was right in the
things he was saying before. Like cuz he in his mind Hasan is
anti-Semitic, right? So, if you just because you criticize Israel,
that doesn't mean even though the anti-Semites will say they
won, it doesn't mean that anti-Semitism is correct. That's what
he's trying to argue, okay? Look at all these people on the far
left. They were calling it a They were calling it a genocide
and apartheid or whatever on October 8th, right? Or or before.
Like these people have been saying this forever. And they're
And, you know, you said before, you know, a ton of different
people vote for you, and you know, you don't have control over
who's voting for you. True, but there's a big difference between
like 20,000 homophobes voted for me versus like I'm So, this
is That's he's suffering from the same thing Kamala Harris did.
If you really came out and like hardcore said, like went made
sure you differentiated, said, "I totally disavow my past comments.
Israel has proven that they are not trustworthy. They have proven
that they actually do have genocidal intent for these people.
They have proven that they have no concern for the safety or
well-being of any of the people in the region." If he came out
and disavowed his past defense of Israel and said, "I was wrong,
and here's what you should do then I think people would have
less criticism. The problem is with This is just like Kamala
Harris, okay? When she was super hardcore to the the social issues.
See, super hardcore. When she was very, very, very left-wing
on social issues, right? She didn't come out and disavow those
positions, those past positions, for her present presidential
She just kind of let them sit there and didn't argue about them,
but she wasn't saying, "No, no, no, those were wrong."
And that's the problem is if you never go and say, "No, that
was wrong." then I think people justifiably think like, "Oh,
you're just trying to get away from positions you generally believe,
but don't ever want to acknowledge were
I'm trying to appeal to homophobic people, you know? So, I I
agree, and then going to the second point is I'm hitting on that
media resonating thing I said before. I definitely agree that
the Democrats need to have a stronger position that they stake
out on it, but my god, like when you're a Republican, you can
walk out on stage. I don't know if Trump ever wakes up sometimes
and like, "I'm just going to do this for fun. I'm going to say
some crazy [__] and see how they defend it." And
everybody everybody will defend it from um Oh my god, who was
it? It wasn't Pam Bondi. Who was that What What big Republican
figure was like, "Oh, it was Megan" I think Megan Kelly was talking
about how banging year olds might not be a big deal. It was a
Yeah. I'm like, "Jesus, what are we talking about here?"
>> Yeah, they were wheeling out the the libertarian fighters.
Like, "Jesus." Meanwhile, if you're on the left, woo, dude. Dude,
it's actually crazy. This conversation's actually insane.
There There's no way This You can't Dude, I this exceeds all
possible expectations.
This conversation has already exceeded all possible expectations
you could have had for this conversation. It's so funny, man.
Kamala Harris and Tim Walls had a tougher interview with I think
it was CNN than I've ever seen Trump have it as a life on any
platform ever. And if you're on the left, man, yeah, I'm seeing
like The New York Times is writing pieces calling Gavin Newsom
homophobic.
And it's like, "How can you stake any position anywhere in this
media environment when the whole right is going to come down
you?" Yeah, everybody on the right looks crazy. >> outlets
that are supposedly more sympathetic end up having to go overboard
to prove how not TDS they are. >> and so I mean, I dude,
look, I think that's a real challenge. Um I want to ask you about
this one thing cuz I the Hasan thing ends up making it very much
about Hasan, and I think that actually deserve the Zoran case
study is more So, what do we get on the Hasan topic? If we're
going to move on, Destiny totally agrees that he hates seeing
He said he hates seeing anti-Semitic attacks on Hasan calling
Hasan an anti-Semite. He hates that.
That was crazy. What else? I mean, he hasn't gotten Tim to acknowledge
anything about Hassan's beliefs, who Hassan is, nothing, and
they're just moving on. So, I don't I thought he was preparing
to like show that Hassan was bad, and then he totally abandoned
that for this combo, I guess. Kind of neat. Kind of interesting.
>> telling Mhm. Um Oh, you know what? You know what this
is? I thought about it a little bit.
I think this is him going, "Oh, I have a chance to like try to
get back into the mainstream. I want this conversation to lead
to additional conversations. I want to be nice to people. I want
to go back on everything I said about having aggressive conversations,
not letting people off the hook. I want to go back to, you know,
in 2024, I made a bad decision on how I was going to interact
with conservatives. I totally regret it. It was a It was a horrible
decision,
and I'm getting my mulligan. I I get my chance to go back and
fix everything. I can be nice to conservatives again. I can figure
it all out, and we can have great conversations. Not so hard.
It was right the whole time, and we're going to rebuild this
media
I don't know if that's going to work, but I do think that's broadly
what he's going to try to do. Uh you skipped the beginning, but
the conversation wasn't about Hassan. Um the conversation was
supposed to be about Hassan. That's what a bunch of Destiny's
notes were about.
Wasn't that what a bunch of the notes were about? Did they abandon
the Hassan conversation? Cuz they brought it up. So, even if
it wasn't about Hassan from the beginning, Sharky Girly, it be
Shark Girly, sorry. It became about Hassan when Tim brought it
up, and Tim literally said, "Here's why I believe in Hassan."
And Destiny went, "Yeah, I'm going to say some that's totally
antithetical to everything I've been arguing for the past like
3 years."
That's when it became about Hassan,
When Destiny totally like knelt to Tim's wisdom on the Hassan
question?
But you're right, you might be right.
You might be right that hey, maybe they said right at the beginning,
"Oh, this isn't going to be about Hasan."
Because I look, I don't I Zohran, if I would have been lived
in New York City, I kept saying on this podcast I would have
ranked him last, but I just wouldn't have ranked Cuomo. Like,
so it would have ostensibly been a vote for him in the end cuz
Cuomo was so bad, but like I would have been for any of the other
random people that were running for mayor. Um he came on my show.
He got the gave the worst answer he gave on any question the
entire campaign on my show about globalizing the intifada
that ended up dogging him. So, I was not like glazing him in
any way, but we did platform him. >> He did walk back on
that on that supporting that quote though, which was good. >> He did
end up walking back, right? So, this is where I'm going with
this. Hasn't Did that help? Did that help them? And and we engaged
with I engaged with them a bunch on the topic of like quote-unquote
abundance-related stuff. It's not just me, but other other people
did as well about like, you know, cutting red Oh, he didn't walk
it back. >> tape, making New York City run better, like
typical, you know, whatever either technocratic left or or classical
liberal right type stuff. And you know, we're in month three,
but he posts anytime that there's a hate crime against people,
he posts about it on social media. He has and there's crimes
happening every day in New York City. So, he, you know, he would
have a reason he couldn't didn't have to, but he does. He posts
about anti-Semitic crimes all the time. He He is cutting red
tape. He's backed off some of his craziest views on stuff. Uh
he kept the New York City police police chief in charge. Like,
isn't Zohran an example of like the big coalition working? Like,
he he took from some of the centrist stuff. He tamped down some
of his lefty stuff. The lefties really are still excited about
him mostly except for like the really crazy ones online, you
know? Um but your average lefty is. A lot of the centrists that
were Another perfectly differentiating factor on Hasan, right?
That like Hasan is still very much enthralled with with Zohran
Mamdani.
And that's a differentiation between him and like the tanky left,
like the super far left types, right? We're not excited with
him. I've kind of gone like, "Okay, he's fine, I guess." You
know? I I Isn't that an example of how the model works? And and
and uh why What's What's wrong with that? What's bad about that?
I mean, that was you and you know, he's not from here, so he
he can't run for president. He wouldn't be my pick if he ran
for president, but like I don't know. I think that at the Bullwark,
us engaging with him ended up being a net plus. Yeah, so here
are my These are like two big things. One is the the biggest
thing. This is like the no-brainer thing, okay? Is um Have you
heard the saying that like the left purity tests and the right
doesn't? You've heard people say this like you might have said
this, right? >> Of course, yeah. This is the least true
thing in the universe, okay? The right absolutely purity tests
you, but they purity test you on your support for the candidate.
Uh I always bring up these two examples infamously unpopular
influencer,
Nicholas J. Fuentes,
infamously,
who I believe has been saying something along the lines of, "I'm
never voting Republican until they fix this. It's total Trump's
totally fake, and I'm voting Democrat now. Vote Democrat in the
midterms." Infamously
unpopular, totally purity tested out of everything guy, Nick
Fuentes. For sure. For Examples, Kyle Rittenhouse floated voting
for a libertarian candidate for like 6 hours because It's so
funny that all of Destiny's talking points are from before his
court case. Like Or Yeah, like basically before that. because
of the bump stock ban from Trump. And that guy was wrapped back
into the fold like that night. And then, I don't know if you
remember, but Joe Rogan on his
Destiny just brought up the example. So, basically they're trying
to find examples of the right purity testing. Destiny's trying
to list them. He gave us Kyle Rittenhouse. When Kyle Rittenhouse
said he was going to not vote for Trump or something, he was
signaling voting for somebody else based on a bump stock ban,
right?
And Kyle Rittenhouse getting bullied. Everybody gets bullied
when they go against the candidate. Kyle Rittenhouse is just
a
That's all. Like everybody gets bullied when they go against
their candidate. You get bullied by a bunch of people. Just depends
on if you stand on business or not. podcast was floating the
idea of supporting RFK, I think as an independent candidate,
and within like a day he walked that back. He was like, "Well,
no, I think I would I think I would support Trump." They're very
big on purity testing on the support for the candidate. And then
outside of that, they don't give a [__] what you
do. As long as you're supporting for the Republican candidate,
they're fine. On the left, they purity test over things that
aren't related to like electoral power or politics, which is
why it seems like there's more on the left because no matter
what you do, you can't get these people to vote for you. So,
the the
They They purity test over things that aren't electoral
or politics. What?
How would that be effective? Why would anybody listen to them
in the first place? If they're just not talking about elections,
they're not talking about things that are political, why would
you even have this conversation? Why would you even bring it
up? The big thing that I look for on the on the on my first point
is, like, do you sup- This is always To me, and I don't remember
this part of the conversation, so this always seems downstream
of Basically, you shouldn't talk about Israel cuz it's a different
country. Right? That's what it seems to be downstream of. Every
single time people go, "You shouldn't talk about Israel. It's
like not a country." It's So, not It's not this country. Then
why are you talking about a different country, man?
Right? Which is always just a soft defense of Israel.
So, I I don't know where he's going to go with this. support
the
politics, which is why it seems like there's more on the left
because no matter what you do, you can't get these people to
vote for you. So, the the big thing that I look for on the on
the on my first point is, like, do you support the party and
the candidate that wins the the primary? One of the big things
that Zoran said, there was a whole series of elections. There
was like 14 of them, and we won every single one like a year
ago. I wish I remember the I don't remember which year it was.
I just know that there were a ton of them. They were a lot of
moderate candidates that that ran in these races. He's talking
about like the New Jersey governor. It was New Jersey, Virginia,
right? And there was Virginia governor and AG, and then Zoran
was one of them. >> races, and I think a couple maybe progressive
ones. Um, what Zoran said was that different See, a year ago,
candidates are appropriate for different races in the country
and we should embrace all of that. And I think that is the exact
correct idea when you acknowledge that like like Zohran is probably
significantly to the left of me. I think he's done a great job
in New York City so far. He's messaging a ton. He's his media
team is amazing at everything they do. Um but I appreciate that
Zohran is not spe- Yeah, it's 5 months ago. It's not even a half
year >> spending his time in a >> Whatever. in a
plus 40 blue area attacking purple Dems constantly, you >> Right.
And that But then when I look at like I can bring it to Hasan,
but like >> didn't do the reverse didn't happen for him.
I mean Hakeem never endorsed him. It took forever. Schumer took
forever. I thought that was a huge strategic mistake. Maybe.
I mean it's a New York City mayor race. I don't know how often
I don't
don't think historically they tend to have that Tim is like Tim
is like flip a coin. Is he going to have a super base position
or a super position? Like flip a coin, he'll say something awesome,
and then the next second he'll be like, "I do agree that like
when Hasan talked about pigs, that was anti-Semitic." I was like,
"Dude, did you Are you serious right now? Are you good?"
No, I just meant like just the na- given the nature of that race,
the establishment Dems should have just been for him. But But
fair I I don't disagree with you. I don't think that Yeah. Well,
you you did disagree. You literally You literally dis-
I can bring it to Hasan, but like >> No, Zohran didn't
do the reverse didn't happen for him. I mean Hakeem never endorsed
him. It took forever. Schumer took forever. I thought that was
a huge strategic mistake. Maybe. I mean it's a New York City
mayor race. I don't know how often I don't think historically
they tend to have that much of a >> meant I think when
you when you're saying, "Well, I don't know if I agree with that."
That's a disagreement. >> No, just the na- given the nature
of that race, the Given the nature of Zohran won the primary,
and somebody who he ran against the primary the Democratic primary,
went against him in the general election. And then basically
a bunch of Democrats refused to endorse him. That is insane.
Could you imagine? Is that not literally the entire point of
this conversation?
You didn't support a guy, he won the primary, and then he wasn't
supported by the party when the guy who lost him in the primary
ran against him in the
You cannot argue this. This is your entire point. You have to
agree with The establishment Dems should have just been for him.
But But fair. >> I I don't disagree with you. I think that
Yeah. Yeah, especially given that populism is having its moment
and all that. But um We know it's entirely It's literally entirely
about
the fact that they ran the primary, Zorn won the
Okay? That's what it's about. And you go through with >> as
Asmongold. What did Asmongold do? >> When you look at how
The Majority Report, how Kyle Kulinski, how Crystal Ball and
Breaking Points, The Young Turks, Hasan. When you look at their
treatment of like the Democratic Party, oh my god, it is brutal.
Brutal. When you go through and you look at how like The Majority
Report, how Kyle Kulinski, how Crystal Ball and Breaking Points,
The Young Turks, Hasan. When you look at their treatment of like
the Democratic Party, oh my god, it is brutal. Brutal. One of
the examples that you brought up earlier was you know, when I
when I talked about my buckets of conversations, one of the biggest
disasters is when you go on and think you're going to have one
convo and you have another. And you actually brought up an example
that I listed which was Ted Cruz going Dude, is their treatment
Their treatment can be brutal when it is like making a decision
that conflicts with their principles, right? But their principles
are like laid out ahead of
The reason it was brutal The reason they're going to talk about
Abigail Spanberger, right? No, no, no, no, no. It was Slotkin.
It was Slotkin who went and had the Breaking Points convo with
Crystal Ball. And it's like, yeah, Slotkin's like unapologetically
pro-Israel, massively pro-Israel, right?
He does take money from AIPAC, but it's different. It's not on
Israel grounds, which I respect. Okay?
And I think that's what they're going to talk about.
And everybody knew what Crystal Ball's what Crystal Ball's position
was on Israel. Everybody knows what her position is. Going on
Tucker Carlson. Yeah. Elissa Slotkin going on Breaking Points.
Exactly. Yeah, and I'm like, "Oh my god, these Dems for the first
time are like, I'm going to try to have this conversation." But
they don't understand where the media environment is. Same thing
with Ted Cruz. He was like, "Tucker Carlson was on Fox, I guess,
so he must be cool." That Slotkin That Slotkin interview lives
rent-free
in every like center-left
pro-Zionist Democrats' mind. That will live forever in their
minds because it's like, dude, that is how hard it is to defend
Israel. Like Elissa Slotkin's not stupid. She can talk. She was
in the
But holy [__] that interview was rough,
okay? Because it's impossible to defend the actions.
That's why it's rough. That's why That's why you can't do it.
And so they all want to call that out and decry that as something
evil to do, something bad to do because they never want to be
in that position themselves.
Well, Tucker Carlson just came back from Moscow showing how amazing
it is that they have bread in their grocery stores. Like, "Jesus
Christ." Um yeah, but those like they're so openly hostile. And
when you have people who weren't even supporting Kamala for president.
Like, I'm sorry, but regardless of your political beliefs, this
was the easiest GED level question of like, "Support Kamala or
Trump?" Even if you cared about Israel and Gaza as a single issue,
Kamala would have been dramatically better. Biden was dramatically
better than Trump on on the Gaza issue. You know, Iran attacked
Israel. We didn't go to war with Iran when when Biden was president.
Um the the inability to support the candidate. We've played this
game over and over and over again where they don't get their
Bernie Sanders. They don't get their ultra-progressive candidate.
I'm just going to keep pointing back to like, you expect this,
but you don't do reciprocity. And so it's becomes very difficult
for you to make this argument sincerely, right? The Zorn thing
is the perfect the perfect example. He won the Dem primary. He
was the Democratic candidate. And then the person who agreed
to run that primary against him, who lost, ran against him in
the general. That to me is the perfect example of oh, we all
need to rally around our candidate that our voters
This is the important This is an important time, and they failed
that test miserably.
Why in the world do you expect
What Why do you expect reciprocity when there's there's nothing
there? Or or like to be given the benefit of the doubt when you
don't even argue for reciprocity. They didn't even argue Sorry.
Yeah, they didn't even make that point on this stream. It just
feels odd, now. >> And then they're And then they're like,
"Oh, whatever." Or it'll be like the weakest, the most tepid
kind of, you know, well, I don't think you should vote for Trump,
but I'm not going to tell you who to vote for kind of thing.
That's unacceptable in my eyes. And when you're courting those
people, and you're trying to make overtures to those people,
I think you're trying to court one, a base that you'll never
truly gather cuz the extremism they want is so far away from
what you can do. And then two, in trying to court those voters,
80% of Cenk's voter or Cenk's viewers voted for Kamala. I just
don't know This is like crazy.
Kyle Kulinski viewers obviously vote left like blue no matter
who. I You You have these voters. The argument should never be
you'll never win these voters. The argument is you have these
voters. Stop trying to talk them until they they basically on
principle say, "Fuck off."
Stop Stop abusing the fact that they have like certain beliefs.
Stop abusing like the Israel issue. Just take the right position
on it. Stop trying to abuse the fact that they really don't have
anywhere else to go to give you justification for not supporting
or for continuing to support Israel. Like that's That's one of
the directions they should go in. >> You're going to have
to move to such extreme positions, you're going to lose more.
And all the polling at least that I've seen is that Democrats
generally want people who are more moderate in views. Yeah. Well,
and this is why And again, this comes back to why this this little
kerfuffle in the discourse about Hasan right now is why I was
so adamant about how dumb it is to fight
the the the third way types are fighting them on their strongest
turf. The far the far left like that crew. Right like honestly,
I mean what the
and this is my frustration with the with those guys on the left
is like since Kamala lost and and Hillary lost anytime in the
discourse now it's like, well, we can't run any centrist anymore
cuz they don't know how to win. And it's like what have you guys
won? Like you guys haven't won anything. Like you haven't won
a single swing state once. Like yeah, try to win something somewhere
that's not a blue state and then I'll listen. What I think, my
personal opinion, nobody has ever tried this Dan Osborne is kind
of trying it in Nebraska right now in a little bit of an imperfect
way. What I really think makes sense for Democrats is to move
to the left on foreign policy cuz that's where the country is.
Move to the left on some economic stuff, probably more left than
I would like on on healthcare whatever, but I just I can read
polls and then cut to the right on cultural stuff. Right? Like
most people in Nebraska are against the war, want
but also like like cops and aren't into woke speak about campus
stuff and you know, also don't you know, want a reasonable immigration
policy. Like that'd be a great compilation of issues. And my
frustration with the left is that that never happens. Right?
They're all you know, it's always it has to be Dude, how much
must it kill people
that Tim is coming out he's arguing exactly what I'm arguing,
exactly what a bunch of people in this audience are arguing and
it's clearly the correct position, right? Clearly. It just feels
good watching cuz I I can't get conversations on this stuff,
but it's clearly the correct position and he's totally dominating
with it. You know, if you're 1 in to their center, you're an
enemy. And that part is crazy and I think that is that is what
why I was saying that was kind of encouraging about Zorn that
he ended up not being like that. He he's ended up being much
more pragmatic than his most annoying fans and I think that's
good and I think that if if we could encourage
there to be other lefty candidates to do stuff like that. I think
that would be a net plus.
Um maybe that's wishful thinking, I don't know, but I think that
engagement is worthwhile on that on that point. You hold the
same position as a never-Trumper Republican, noted. As long as
that position is, run your standard liberal candidates and let
them criticize Israel and stop pretending that that's like some
purity test you should be doing. Yes. Yes, I I agree on that
point, yeah. 100%. But also like, you know, calling them out
when they're doing stuff that is dam- damaging is also good.
I I think not just in the way that we're talking about circling
back to the original conversation, not about how the left concedes
to MAGA a lot. I definitely don't think the central left should
concede to the far left on electability. And you are seeing some
of that out there. And um and and so, but a part of the way to
do that is to win and show you don't
I might agree with that. It would depend on where we're coming
from and what the strategy is, right?
Tim, that is ideologically, he's never going to say, "Oh, yeah,
you guys should talk to the lefties and agree with them." That
like a paradigm shift is required. Of course he's never going
to agree with that, right? Like that's that's totally he's a
never-Trumper.
Like a never-Trumper Republican. That that's like anathema to
his whole way of life. Of course he's not. So, I I don't take
this like seriously. This is like a major ideological difference.
I never expected Tim to have any other position on this. No,
to win and to be pragmatic and practical as well. And I just
think that like fighting them on foreign policy in the middle
of the Iran or fighting them on Israel right now in the middle
of this war is just is insane behavior. Bye. >> Yeah. I
don't necessarily disagree agree, although I will say I don't
necessarily disagree. Bro, you've been posting about Hassan 10
times a day for the past 2 weeks. What?
5 10 times a day.
What do you mean you don't necessarily disagree? You You staunchly
You vehemently disagree. No?
What? What do you mean? You You Oh, I don't necessarily disagree.
You have to disagree. Otherwise, what have you been posting about?
say that that they can the way that Dude, this is crazy
that Hassan has won so hard that Destiny could spend 2 weeks
on Twitter doing nothing but posting about what an anti-Semitic
illiberal he is. And then Tim comes in and goes, "Hey, don't
fight these guys on Israel." And Destiny goes, "I don't necessarily
disagree."
What? that they operate as identical to the right in that the
grounds that you're fighting on are almost always going to be
dictated by them. Like, if you listen to any of these people,
these people have been talking about and obsessively talking
about Israel-Palestine for years, and it is the only thing they
talk about. You can show up to any of these platforms to debate
or argue, and they and it will I mean, you know, you mentioned
with Sockit, right? It's going to get dragged back to Israel-Palestine.
And then the answers that they're wanting from you >> Well,
why not just give them the W on that and then move on and try
to move on to other stuff? Try to move them on other stuff. >> Because
the only W they would take would be like you're in favor of like
the abolition of the state of Israel, which is like it's so far
and you're just so out there. Yeah, which is why I think it's
important to have an in No. No. No, this is a totally fake. This
is an obviously and totally
fake idea.
Dude, there's no way you think that Oh, the second the second
we see any ground on Israel, they're going to say Israel's to
be abolished. What? Nobody thinks that's realistic. Nobody Nobody
agrees with this. What? with Sockit, right? It's going to get
dragged back to Israel-Palestine.
And then the answers that they're wanting from you are always
going to be dragged back to Israel-Palestine. And then the answers
that they're wanting from you are always going to be dragged
back to Israel-Palestine. And then the answers that they're wanting
from you are always going to be dragged back to Israel-Palestine.
And then the answers that they're wanting from you are always
going to be dragged back to Israel-Palestine. And then the answers
that they're wanting from you are always going to be dragged
back to Israel-Palestine. That's not the only W they would take.
That's not the only Dude, these guys actually believe that if
Democrats came out tomorrow and said, "We're We're Our party
platform is now the pausing of all funding, the pausing of all
weapons agreements, the the total rollback of all weapons agreements
with Israel until they've done something to fix the the situation
with the Palestinians. If they came out and said that, you're
telling me that you think Hassan, Sam Seder, Kyle Kulinski, Krystal
Ball, these people would not come out and celebrate. It's totally
insane, and it's not the argument he was making before, right?
That's not the argument he was making ever before Well, it was
one of it was one that he started making around the time of the
Hassan hypotheticals. Well, he's going to nuke
It's delusional.
It's completely and utterly delusional. Abolish Israel has a
wide range of meaning. Sure, sure, sure, sure. It might be like,
"Hey, Israel needs to make changes." Right? But there's no reason
to think Hassan's going to go and like use the military to destroy
Israel before exhausting all possible economic and diplomatic
options.
Right? Like you probably have longer than one presidency could
possibly accommodate to try to fix the Israel problem. Anyway,
we continue. >> It gets so far and you're just so out there.
Yeah, which is why I think it's important to have an anti like
a like a generally less war position. I mean, I say anti-war,
I guess, but I I think we should support Ukraine and >> Anti-war,
yeah. Yeah, we've got to figure out Yeah, anti-war. But I can't
But if you're perceived as immediately capitulating to these
people on the far left, If we take an anti-Israel position, then
the anti-Semites win.
Is genuinely the argument right now. We can't do that. We can't
capitulate to them. We'll be seen as capitulating to the anti-Semites.
Hey, they're like literally They're doing an ethnic cleansing
in Lebanon right now.
They're setting C4 off and detonating entire villages.
After they chase the people out, they're going to the villages,
setting C4 in the houses, and blowing them all up. Are you seriously
saying Are you seriously doing the meme? They're doing the meme.
Hold on. They're doing the meme. They're doing the meme. They're
doing the meme. Thank you, Vaush, for putting it so eloquently,
okay? I should just say it myself, but >> It should be
understood that the unambiguous position of the Democratic Party
and the Republican Party right now is that they expect their
voters to choose between the feelings of people and the future
of the United States. Um this is a fact. There is no room for
argument on this. It should be under This is a fact. This is
a fact. This cannot be argued with. Dude, if we if we do this,
we're going to be seen as capitulating to these people.
Okay, but are you capitulating? No. Then why are you bringing
it up?
Why don't you like Israel? Doesn't Israel have the right to exist?
Dude, get the get out of here, man. >> understood that
the unambiguous position of the Democratic Sorry, I hit play
on this instead of the actual kickbot. >> it becomes very
easy for people on the far right to kind of attack you. One thing
that I think people don't realize, and the far right is so good
at this, the far right is very cognizant that people on the far
left do not represent a threat to them at all. Wait. Wait.
Because the far right will attack you on
What does he mean by far right? Cuz to me, the far right of the
Republicans,
those guys are pretty famously
not fans of Israel. I'm just saying. Who does he mean by the
far right now? I think we should support Ukraine against Yeah,
I was going to say we got to figure out They got to listen to
this again. But if you're perceived as immediately capitulating
to these people on the far left, it becomes very easy for people
on the far right to kind of attack you. One thing that I think
people don't realize So far left being Hasan, far right of course
would mean like the Tucker Carlson, Nick Fuentes version of the
right wing. So that makes no sense. And the far right is so good
at this, the far right is very cognizant that people on the far
left do not represent a threat to them at all. And you can tell
because they always use the far left to attack like moderate
left Democrats, but they don't >> Yep. just attack but
when they're attacking moderate left Democrats, they try to destroy
them, right? So like Jimmy Kimmel and everybody, you know, it
was like the FCC get this show taken off the air. But nobody
is like bringing all this pressure onto like these very far left
people to like deplatform them, you know? Like they they like
the fact they exist there cuz they can always use them as a useful
cudgel to attack other Democrats. Yeah, you you know what? You're
actually right. I've never heard anybody in the far right say
Hasan [__] is like a lunatic. I've never heard anybody
in the MAGA administration say Hasan [__] sucks.
Definitely Fox has never covered him. They definitely weren't
the people who basically ran with that entire Cuba story like
2 weeks ago. Absolutely not. You're right, Destiny. They never
go after Hasan. They've never gone after Hasan.
Dude, who the [__] is planting stories in New York
Post about Zohran Mamdani's wife every single week?
I could have sworn that was the far right. I could have sworn
New York Post was far right. Am I wrong?
At least in this analogy where he is clearly saying far right
to mean MAGA, okay? That's That is what he's talking about. He
just said MAGA, right?
baffling. Truly baffling these arguments he makes. That's why
I'm Yeah. Yeah. I'm checking myself on this cuz it's always like,
you don't want to fight the last war and I don't you know, maybe
I have too much PTSD from being in there. But like, I lived this
battle on the other side already, right? Like losing the mod-
the fight from the far right to the moderates within the Republican
Party. And part of the mis- you know, among the mistakes that
were made,
True. J.D. Vance. J.D. Vance brought up Krystal getting shocked
in an interview or at least acknowledge it, talked about >> Laughed
about it. uh number one, not believing that the far right could
actually win ever. Um and I That was just a huge mistake from
the center right and the center left. You know, just strategically
speaking, like empowering Trump was like Hey, please I need you
to think of how and why the Republican base moved away from their
establishment candidates, okay? What did you do? What did you
do? What did Trump do different? And what did you guys do in
response?
You guys reflexively, you guys literally did what Destiny was
trying to do, right? Reflexively double down on the on the positions
that are unpopular,
giving them an open lane with the popular positions such that
they can outflank you and basically uproot your entire party.
This happened with the Iraq War. This happened with uh there's
there's the Iraq War and like two other things. I I probably
racism, like basically saying stuff's racist, like immigration
policy's racist. They started doing some of that. Jeb Bush was
doing some of That wasn't flying with the Republican base, okay?
You took the worst positions reflexively because Trump had dug
out ground on some wedge issue and instead of saying, "You know
what? He's actually right on that." and absorbing that to taking
a little bit of a loss, but not dying, not getting
they fought him on these issues repeatedly. And basically, I
think Destiny and Co. are suggesting doing the same thing over
Israel right now. Literal strategy. >> the Hillary campaign
as well as the moderate Republican campaigns in in 2016 cuz I
thought that, "Okay, well, he could never win in the end." And
here we go. So, I think that just not falling for that. I hear
you. The far left is not as as as popular as the mega right is,
but you know, just not making that same mistake, I think, would
be smart. Um and and secondly, just I I think that
made a mistake on the center-right being like not ever wanting
to hand it to the you know, could we could we have gained credibility
with the base by
saying, "Yeah, the Iraq War, we stood
Oh, thank you. That's what you're advocating for, Tim. You're
advocating for Democrats to not make the same mistake Republican
You can think that challenging these people who are sort of outside
of your party apparatus, who are sort of like, you know, edgy,
new people that are that are like trying to argue they're like
the new vibe, the new
base of the party, right? The way you lose to them is by making
them, I'm going to use this word a lot, anathema, the the like
ontologically evil and wrong, and then arguing the positions
that are popular that they're arguing for are wrong with no argument
at all. Just going, "It's really bad. This guy's a bad guy. This
guy's a bad guy. He doesn't support our troops. He said he said
John McCain got captured. He doesn't like that. He doesn't like
guys who got captured. He's disgusting.
Yeah, no. That's that's the wrong Just say war bad. That's what
your whole base wants to hear. War bad.
Do not throw away your entire advantage just because you've decided
that these people can't be agreed with on anything.
It's insane. >> up. We shouldn't have been spending so
much money on these foreign wars. We should have spent more money
at home. Uh um, you know, yeah, the you know, the border got
out of control. I don't know. Like there were various things
like the pot Hold on. I'm going to pull this back cuz I do want
to answer this mute comment. The interesting thing is though
is that Republicans were trying to shy away from the Iraq war
at the time because they saw polling, okay? And here's what happened.
Only mute. They saw polling. They knew it wasn't popular. They
were slowly shying away. Donald Trump came in, smashed them,
said, "Hey, you guys are morons who supported this. You all supported
this, right?" And he had Jeb Bush there whose brother brought
about the Iraq war. And Jeb Bush was willing to double down and
say, "No, no, no. My brother was a great president." Right? So
he had a figurehead to look for him. All of them had sort of
backed off of it entirely, yes. But Trump was the one who came
in and said, "Uh the difference between me and them is that I
never supported Iraq." Which was a lie, by the way. He found
out that lying doesn't really get you over that hard, okay?
But yes, he it was unpopular and their reaction to Trump coming
in and and like a wrecking ball taking that position was to go,
"Actually, you. No, support our
And led to disastrous results.
Unfortunate, man. Like we [__] up. We shouldn't have
been spending so much money on these foreign wars. We should
have spent more money at home. Uh um, you know, yeah, the you
know, the border got out of control. I don't know. Like there
were various things like the I also just forgot
that we have the literal guy
who ran the campaign
that set this all up. I forgot that Tim is the literal guy who
ran the Jeb Bush campaign. He was the campaign manager for Jeb
Bush. I forgot. Yeah, so Tim has unique experience in this precise
thing up. I will give him props though. It's not easy for people
to truly change and it sounds like he's going, "I had the worst
idea back then. I had the I had terrible ideas of what we should
be doing and I'm not willing Oh, communications director. Sure,
sure, sure. He's on the campaign.
And he had they had terrible ideas for what they should be doing,
right?
And so he is actually doing the smart thing and going, "I was
I [__] up. I made a mistake. We made a mistake. Don't
make that same mistake we made."
So, congratulations to Tim for actually making that that differentiation.
It's hard to change. It's hard to change some base level opinion
like that. Right? The Oh, these people are are bad to me. I I
hate them. I think they're morally like they're they're bordering
on evil.
But I'm not going to disagree with them on that. I'm not going
to let them change me at all. I don't know how Dems aren't taking
advantage of how badly Trump's
Well, unfortunately, what makes the Dems so unpopular right now?
There's a lot of things that make the Dems unpopular right now.
Ever wanting to hand it to the you know, could we could we have
gained credibility with the base by
saying, "Yeah, the Iraq War, we [__]
Like we [__] up. We shouldn't have been spending
so much money on these foreign wars. We should have spent more
money at home. Um you know, yeah, the you know, the border got
out of control." I don't know. Like there were various things
like the populist right was upset about and the establishment
on the right refused to engage with them on and so like duh duh,
they overthrew the establishment. Kind of. You know, so anyway,
so I think that that like those two things like both kind of
hang in my head when I think about this the framework of this
thing too. I definitely I definitely agree. Like there are times
when you can't be obstinate on every change, especially when
the winds are blowing in a certain direction. But I think um
harking back again to that media model, I think it's It's important
to keep in mind like what are real issues versus what are fake
You know, I trigger the kind of everybody when I say certain
things but like like I stand by this. Like illegal immigration
was that was a fake issue. That was just not a real thing. And
my evidence of that, and I argue with every single conservative
on this, my evidence of that was if you cared about illegal immigrants
at the border, there was a huge bill, right? Lankford sent it
from the Senate. There was a huge bill to close the border and
Donald Trump, not a conspiracy, right? You saw him say it. Ted
Cruz already said
Totally disagree. Um I I totally disagree on this.
Uh Biden Biden had the ability to shut the border down. You had
this argument,
You had this argument for so long as
said, "I can't shut the border down. It's like not constitutional.
I can't do it." Right? You had this argument. Unfortunately,
about 6 9 months before the election,
he by executive order shut the border down. No, you lose this
Do you lose this argument every time? They said, "No, this isn't
good enough." They knew they had you by the balls. You guys tried
to negotiate. You tried to play it smart. You ended up ended
up tremendously. Trump did say, "Yeah, don't don't pass this.
Yeah, no, they're they're losing on it. They did Don't pass it."
He did say that. But they all ran behind the idea that like,
"Oh, well, huh actually it's just not enough."
And you'll never be able to convince people otherwise because
Biden and and did shut down the border and blew the whole thing
up.
Unlucky. Biden is Biden is a great president. This was probably
the defining mistake of his presidency. You had to pick a direction.
You had to pick a lane and he split the baby in half and he everything
up for everybody, okay? >> Donald Trump said, "Kill that
bill. I want to get into office." Donald Trump comes into office.
First he said 15 million illegal immigrants. Then it went to
20 25. Now 30 million illegals came in under Biden and they haven't
really done anything to deport these 30 million people. I think
2 million was their largest estimate. Now everybody hates ICE
and he I guess he shut down the border but like how are you telling
me that you cared so much 30 million illegals came in under Biden?
Is that the number? What you about immigration illegal immigration
but now nobody talks about it anymore except for when Trump is
sending ICE agents around to assassinate American citizens. And
then you've got you know, apparently there are still 28 million
illegals here, but Republicans just don't seem to care about
it as much anymore. They Oh, he just he just misspoke. >> See
what I mean when I say like I don't believe this is a real issue.
This is a manufactured issue that Republicans >> okay,
okay. I he's saying what Trump says. Okay. >> front of
you. You can have strong feelings about it, but much like there
weren't drag queens that were indoctrinating 20% of American
children, there weren't Haitians actually eating cats and dogs.
And J.D. Vance admitted in that interview, yeah, you know, we're
going to make an issue up to get you to care about it. He said
it. It's crazy. And yeah, that So I think when you're fighting
against something I think you have to be very careful not >> I
I think Tim totally disagrees here and he's just letting Destiny
cook, right? Like he's just trying not to argue. to capitulate
to issues where I think you should say like yes, we acknowledge
Americans have strong feelings about immigration. This is why
we're trying to do this on the border whatever, but the Republicans
can't get to control the framing because what happens is you
have these problems that aren't real, meaning you can never fix
them because nothing you do is going to be enough. And then when
they come into office, they don't even have to do anything to
fix them. Mexico never built a wall. Like none of the this stuff
ever even happened. I had a guy telling me he was so happy about
how ICE and the Department of Homeland Security everything was
working like I you'll never get me to disagree with this one,
okay?
MAGA voters are completely at this point. If you're a MAGA supporter,
you basically have shown if we could do one test, I wouldn't
even do an IQ test. I would say do you still trust Donald Trump
at this point? If you say yes, no, you're out. You you cannot
vote. I'm That's the That's the bar, okay? You actually are not
possibly you you you're not capable. You should not have the
right. Okay? Fell for the Dude, I There was a great fell for
it again award meme. Hold This is This is so true on multiple
levels. Give me a second. It's this one. This is like the entire
MAGA movement right now. Jingling keys. Guys, we just rescued
that pilot. Guys, we just rescued that pilot. Oh, look over here.
We rescued the pilot. We rescued the pilot. Look, look, look.
Every single time, man. Every single It's so embarrassing.
I would be embarrassed to share a country with these people,
dude. It's rough.
Like 2 days ago when I was at UCLA, and they just fired Kristi
Noem. How could you possibly be happy with that? What are you
talking about? Um it's not a reality game, right? They They make
up issues, they put it in front of you, and then you get really
mad about it. Well, how are you supposed to fix the issue? >> I
know, we're too rational. I do agree with that. We're too rational.
I always have felt like that was a weakness for me as a boss,
as well. Maybe it's a weakness as a content creator. You know,
the good Tim is Tim is not joking here, by the way. He is saying
that. He's like, yeah, it's um
Like I actually am too rational. And to some extent, that's the
thing. That's also the problem is you've picked you've staked
out the position of rationality, right? That's the core identity
of the Democrats right now is you are trying to be the rational
fact-based actors, and in a world where that is increasingly
being weaponized against you. You can abandon it entirely, but
I
And maybe you are Maybe people would could argue you should,
but it's like, dude, I I don't want to live in that world where
it's just unironically like everybody propagandizing everybody
else, just who has the best propaganda? It feels like it'd be
[__] up, man. Good bosses demand irrational things
about half of their underlings. Sure, yeah. Um but I hear that.
I Yeah, I hear it. I don't know. I don't know how to fix that.
The media thing, that when you when you have when you control
so much, you can push any message you want. Again, I'm not saying
we should do it, but at the very least we have to disrupt the
other side to do it. Otherwise, they can just push anything they
want, and it just it's insane to me. Um this is my last thing
to to bring up to be cognizant of, okay? Cuz I see um Sarah's
going through it right now um
on on Twitter. The way that MAGA argues and the way that these
like far left people argue, and you can always see the way they
do it, is um whenever there's like an a disagreement or a big
issue, uh you can never actually have an argument on the substance
of any of these topics ever. It will always Dude, I'm pretty
sure
Did he not argue with like all of the champions of that movement?
Like Like dude, did he not argue with Norm Finkelstein? Did he
not have substantive debates with all of these people?
That's the core issue. That's the big one they have. What do
you mean there's no substantive debate? >> Please be You
ignore the subject matter. You pivot to something different.
Maybe you something you morally grandstand on. You attack your
opponent by misrepresenting them or ascribing to them some other
crazy belief that might not even be related. And then And then
you just repeat this over and over and over and over and over
again. And that is the only way that these people engage. And
the reason why they can do it is when you go back to those conversation
buckets I listed earlier, all of these people only cycle through
the same team conversations or the friendly PR conversations.
Everybody does it on MAGA. There are no real like debate people.
And everybody does it on the far left. So, when Hassan is fighting
somebody, you'll see all Is Norm not supremely bad faith? I'll
be
I can't be the only person. And I'm going to be brutally honest
with you
Still ain't never watched that debate. Almost certainly will
never ever watch that debate. I couldn't be I couldn't care less
about that Miss me with that Okay? No chance I'm watching that
debate ever. Okay? No chance I'm watching that debate ever.
No that [__] Get it out of here. Yeah, the Norm Finkelstein
debate, never watched it. And I was like friends with this whole
group of people when it came out. I had no interest. No interest
at all. All the usual suspects you know, pop up like Ryan Grim
is going to be there supporting him. >> Although I will
say I did watch the Breaking Points
moderated debate
with I can't remember the guy's name now. He was debating this
a lot. That guy's got to be doing like tours now just bragging
about how correct he was, right? Omar, yeah. That was substantive.
I think that was very substantive, no? That felt like it was
a good debate. Emma Vigeland is going to be there supporting
him. All the maybe Rana Joy Gray depending. All of these people
come out and they'll defend any position possible as long as
they're on the same team. And remember the I just think the message
that that sends, like if I'm getting these people in my algorithm,
they're so right on everything. That's the world I live in. They're
able to castigate these other people as adversaries and evil
Nazis and everything else. And yeah, it's so hard to break through
that, but like yeah, I think it's important to be cognizant of
the way these people fight. >> narrative. No, I'm cognizant
of it and I uh this is true for every every group, but like guys,
these people control the narrative. You don't understand how
well this Cenk Uygur controls the narrative. Controls the narrative.
He controls it. Ryan Grim just this loser today. Jesus.
That's a very rude thing to say. Okay, I'll look at this Ryan
Grim thing. It's it seems like a good good place to pause. Apparently
these lefties just control the narrative. They're totally controlling
of the narrative. Let's see here. What did Ryan Grim say? In
2021 and 2022, Cenk Uygur 25's firm made $950,000
each year from the Coke network, according to Stand Together's
tax filings. This is who is telling Democrats what streams they
should and shouldn't go on.
So, Long Well Partners compensation
And then Destiny has a response to this. What is the response
to this? Give me a second. Oh, if you were cashing Coke checks
in 2022, I don't think you have standing to nitpick a streamer's
comments from like a decade ago. That is very true, right? People
do change over time. If you're going to take the, you know, America
deserved 9/11 comment and constantly throw that in his face,
then it's totally fair totally fair for Ryan Grim to go, "Hey,
you're cashing checks from the Coke
Off. I have no interest in hearing your
Totally totally reasonable. Sounds completely reasonable to me.
Let's see the Destiny response.
Firm made $950,000 a year. May it's a 501c3 nonprofit. They aren't
making money. 501c3 nonprofit.
Long Well Partners, okay.
Do you know what makes it so you don't earn a profit really easily?
Do you know what Do you know what makes it really easy to not
earn a profit? Paying yourself a massive salary.
I guess you probably have to know what she spent the money on,
right? It's a consulting firm, dunce. Longwell
Yeah, so like
she's getting paid for consulting. She's getting the money into
her company. Now, maybe she maybe she wasn't taking very much
money, right? Be nice. There's nothing about There's nothing
on Wikipedia about any of this. So, there's no way for him to
know. Dude,
all these people all these people are totally crushing this guy.
Dude, 1.2K likes, 3.5K likes. Uh-oh. I don't know why he keeps
doing this to
This By the way,
this is a guy who would defend Z, right? And I don't for to be
fair, I've I actually didn't make this allegation about Z. I
don't know how much she earns. I don't know if she takes very
much off the top. I've no idea. But, it's like he clearly doesn't
know what he's saying
when he responds. It's a 501c3. She can't make money off of that.
Nobody has ever made money off of a 501c3 before. You're true.
So so amazing. You're right. Wow. Wow.
It's a humiliation kink, remember? I do unfortunately recall
that now. Now that you mention it.
Did Destiny respond to this? This guy thinks nonprofits profits
are sacrosanct in America. Right, it's a stupid point to begin
with, but it's also incorrect. Okay. All right. Kyle joined in.
Oh, no. Kyle joined in. My goat my goat Kyle Kulinski joined
in? What? Can @KyleKulinski or anyone please explain how one
of the most effective critics of that genocide, who's been covering
Israel-Palestine for over a decade, doesn't know what the Western
Wall is? Does he know anything about Al-Aqsa? Oh, Destiny, are
you going to are you going to do the oh, you didn't know this
random fact thing? Destiny of all people, you didn't know this
random fact so you're totally wrong? Oh, boy. Somebody Somebody
get the clip of this guy looking at a map while debating Israel-Palestine,
not being able to find the Mediterranean
Sea.
Like first news. Which by the way, I don't really criticize people
on that, you know. I I you can not know like a little fact about
something and have a pretty comprehensive knowledge around that
>> Story. Sarah Huckabee Sanders visits the Western Wall.
>> Literally, this is the one thing about Judaism that
I do not know. Like I mean, we I've learned deep lore on this
broadcast about Sukkot, about the citrus, about the stick and
the tent. Is just a holy wall? I don't know. Wait, what the You
don't know >> Oh, no. Is it a conduit clip? Is it a conduit
clip? No.
You How do you not know? You're Why do Christians go there and
like cry? If this is not Okay, there's probably some some
some gamesmanship happening here, okay? When Hasan's getting
called and called out and getting critiqued for being anti-Semitic,
it is a five-head play to go, "The Western Wall? I ain't never
heard of that. What's the Western Wall?" Because if you don't
know this, this is something people like to joke about, right?
Make anti-Semitic jokes about. Oh, you kissed the wall, you're
a total piece of We can't trust you. You kissed the wall. Right?
So, for Hasan to go, "Oh, gee shucks. I don't know about that
wall. What's that wall? I don't know what that wall is." It's
like a little bit It could be gamesmanship.
at the same time, if it's not, you have to admit he's not an
anti-Semite, okay? It's just obviously clear he's not an anti-Semite
if he literally doesn't know what kissing the wall means.
What is the wall? It's the remain last remaining wall of the
second temple, I think. The last remaining standing piece of
the second temple, which is the temple built in Jerusalem, right?
It's Now Now Al-Aqsa is built on top of it on the foundation.
Also called the Wailing Wall, I think. I believe it is also called
the Wailing Wall, yes.
Hold on, we got two tweets here. We got another Dusty tweet.
We got a Jackson Hinkle tweet. Hold on. Let's take a look. Oh,
Kyle responding. Oh, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Can't even find
Israel on a map. Uh He find it now. Yeah, what? >> Dude,
I don't know. I I don't know how you look at this and it is like
I'll give it to you, it's the names are different because it's
a Roman map, right?
But like not being able to just locate the Mediterranean Sea
seems goofy. >> With this whole thing or
So uh as far as I can tell, Asmongold's suspension got lifted,
guys, but I don't know. Someone let me know. The light
>> The boot. The boot, man. The boot. The boot and then
the Mediterranean. It's so >> is Palestinia. Wait, what
light green? Oh wait, I'm sorry. I'm looking at the wrong area.
This is Turkey. Oh, here. Okay. With With this whole
Dude, I don't know if he found it there but he at the end. I
don't know if he actually found it. He like zoomed in. I don't
know if he's like watch Is he like watching the chat doing hot
and cold? Is he playing Marco Polo?
Appropriate way to do it, I suppose. Marco. Polo. Hot, cold.
Hotter, colder, hotter, colder.
I It doesn't I'll say you can have a really in-depth knowledge
of the history of Israel and not know how to find it find it
on a map. That is possible,
I just I don't make fun of people for that. He is making fun
of people for that. It's goofy. For him to do it. Oh, Hasan doesn't
know what the Western Wall is. Iron stuff. I'm going to be real,
it's not much. It's the outside wall of the Second Temple. This
is the Temple Mount, mega holy, great place to pray. How has
he been doing commentary on Israel-Palestine for so long and
he doesn't know about the Western Wall? It's one of the main
points of contention and nego >> Oh, he just he just brainlessly
ripped the Conduit argument for himself but he didn't think about
how that makes him look and his previous look at all. Oh boy.
Oh boy. tiations for the two-state solution. >> It's just
the [__] It's just the wall, man. Calm down. Like
I I just politicians are doing the classic like we're going to
Israel to show how
uh to to show how much we love Israel.
Uh is Oh, who is Conduit? Conduit's like a a YouTuber who took
a bunch of the like DGG clips and stuff and the arguments they
make about Hasan and a bunch of other people and made videos
specifically for DGG on their new arc
of hating
like I guess I guess SocDems, hating them. Very cool.
So, basically from here, Cenk Uygur follows up with this video.
>> I don't know who Francisco Franco is, but he must be
a [__] loser. >> You don't know Francisco Franco?
>> He's got $2 supporters. Bro. $2 supporters. Yeah.
Bashar al-Assad, is that this guy?
Okay, this was rough. This was rough. Is this Is Is this Bashar
al-Assad right here? Is this Bashar al-Assad?
This was tough, man.
This This was rough, okay?
It's Erdoğan. No.
Wait, what's your Wait, who is this Who are these people? Am
I just supposed to
This isn't him. Oh, Erdoğan Erdoğan. Erdoğan.
Bro. Actual Sorry, it's going to be a lot of this same thing,
okay? >> supporters Bro. >> $2 It's bro.
Bro. You good?
You good, bro?
Sorry. You're supposed to know?
This isn't him. Oh, Erdoğan Erdoğan. Erdoğan. Erdoğan. No, that's
place you're bombing right
Is it Erdoğan Erdoğan? I don't know who that guy's name.
When did he become
That's insane.
That's That's like not not knowing maps. I sort of Well, I I
can't perceive not knowing maps cuz I like actually like history
stuff. So, I've just always known this cuz it's always been cool
to me. So, I can't perceive what it's like to not know that.
But, to not know who Erdogan is or that his name is Erdogan,
you were friends with Hassad. I thought Destiny was joking here.
I He's definitely not joking, is he? >> President of Israel.
Or or Yahweh. >> gospel President of Israel. What? It was
originally written in Greek? Yes. I don't think that one was
a joke. There is one where he is joking. Okay. Yeah. Not Arabic
or whatever or No. They were written in Koine Greek.
Well, Hebrew and there There was some Aramaic in the Old Testament
as well. Okay. Aramaic. Got you. But but mostly mostly Hebrew.
Yeah.
Okay. I'll take it. All right. Okay. Okay. Not too bad. Not too
bad.
Now, Destiny responded to this with
pretty classic. This is classic. I've openly said I didn't know
all about Israel-Palestine until October 7th and I started doing
research on it. In 6 months I was able to debate your best scholars
on it and crush them. See Finkelstein, rip.
Did Why is he setting himself up for the cookie clip to get played
now? Why is he setting himself up for the cookie thing? Now,
I don't think you crushed Finkelstein. I Maybe I would You know,
all I've ever seen is clips of Finkelstein talking [__]
and not engaging.
I don't think that's crushing him. I think that's he just was
the whole time,
What's the cookie thing? Destiny argued that the rockets in Palestine
are fueled by cookies.
Like basically they're not allowed to Essentially, the argument
on both sides is the Israelis block like different sugars, cookies,
candy, these stuff like this from going into Gaza. Because they
say it could be used to make propellant for rockets. And while
that is technically true, like the amount you would need is pretty
insane. And it's more like finished products they don't let in,
like cookies, chips, this kind of thing. Realistically, they
send all the sugar in that they would need to make sugar like
fuel anyway.
It's just like they don't want them to have candy and stuff,
which is literally some testimony they've given with regards
to
when they originally put the the ban in it was after Palestinians
captured some Israeli soldier and they didn't want it the idea
of them like eating cookies or chips like upset them. Right?
They just They justified or he justified the embargo on sugar
based off the myth that sugar was being pre-purposed to rockets.
Well, it is a myth. It is technically possible to make rocket
fuel with sugar. There is like a a mix of stuff you can do, right?
but it just isn't being done in this case. They had literally
factories that made cookies in Gaza. Like there were pounds and
pounds of of sugar being allowed in. It was just the finished
product. Being able to sell that nice finished product was what
they didn't want, right?
Okay. Anyway. And the rest avoid the debate for good
Oh, is I I think this is Destiny offering to take debates on
Israel-Palestine, right?
Is this not Destiny offering to take debates right now on Israel-Palestine?
No, no, no, no, no, not like that. Not not not now. We We debate
the history, guys.
Cuz I'm claiming to have known about Israel-Palestine for over
a decade and doesn't know literally the most important landmark
in the country.
I mean the Arab is way more important, but like it's like the
Arab way more important now.
Honestly, if the Western Wall got destroyed, I don't know I don't
know there'd be an uprising. If you blew up the the Temple of
the Rock the the Dome of the Rock or whatever Temple of the Al-Aqsa
Temple. If you blew that up, Al-Aqsa Mosque, sorry, not Temple.
I don't know why I said that. Trying to trigger people. If you
blew that up, you
like basically cause World War like like this is something people
universally agree with. If that gets blown up, it's like, "Okay,
all hands on deck. Israel got to go." And by the way, that would
be including if Iran hit it with a
Like I think basically if that gets blown up, nobody's going
to believe that Israel had nothing to do with it and they're
all going to treat Israel as if they had something to do with
it. Like that's the whole region explodes.
The the Holy Sepulchre Church thing, yeah, that's also there.
There are important landmarks. I'm just saying the way the Wailing
Wall, the Western Wall is probably not the most important
There are probably more important
I guess maybe if you're you could say it's the most important
one. But I think the I think people actually have to the whole
thing. They have um to the whole like Temple Mount. They have
a pretty strong tie, so.
Not super relevant. So he just Does Kyle respond? He does not
respond yet. Keep me up to date on this, okay? We've There we
go. There's a little cut out, little palate cleanser, some tweets.
Let's roll back in this conversation. I'm going to move it back
about 30 seconds. Yeah, about 30 seconds and we'll keep listening
from here. >> supporting him. Um Emma Vigeland is going
to be there supporting him. All the Maybe Brittany Joy Gray depending.
All of these people come out and they'll defend any position
possible as long as they're on the same team. And remember the
I just think the message that sends like if I'm getting these
people in my algorithm, they're so right on everything. That's
the world I live in. They're able to castigate these other people
as adversaries and evil Nazis and everything else. And yeah,
it's so hard to break through that But like I think it's important
to be cognizant of the way these people are fighting the >> No,
I'm cognizant of it and I um Uh this is true for every every
group, but like I think just picking battles is very important
in this world. Um you know, and um So anyway, uh I I think that's
uh informs my perspective on this one. Yeah, no, Sarah's definitely
in the barrel right now. Yeah. It's like I don't know.
I know you can never I've been there. I
uh and one thing that you can never tell somebody in that is
in the barrel is that they should stop because they're having
the fight in their head and they refuse and they and so you know
Dude, what the Gay dudes really do hate women, don't
Sarah's basically just having a little shadow boxing event in
her head. She's fighting demons. Uh you know, you can't really
You can't really do anything, can you? Classic woman. Classic
woman.
Very funny. Hello, Harjatour. Thank you for the 10 gifted subs.
Let's go. That's 10 gifties. We need two more for another 2 hours
on the stream, guys. Get those two in now so we can just add
it to the clock, all right? Thank you so much, Harjaat Tour,
for the 10 gifted. Huge, massive thank you so much. Appreciate
it. Sometimes you just got to let it let it burn out. Yeah. Yeah,
that's the thing. I'm sure if you've been through it, you always
tell people like just wait like 4 days and it'll be so much better,
I promise. But yeah, person's first journey through internet
hell is always the toughest to go through cuz they're like, "It's
over, bro." It's like I've been I've been in fetal position before,
so you know, I think I got it now. Then we'll see. Okay, cool.
Um yeah, anything else you want to Dude, I appreciate this. Um
it's been overdue. Uh and um and we can just keep keep in touch,
you know, give me tips, pointers. incredibly, incredibly important
monuments to I think most people
Like everybody everybody cares about everything on the Temple
Mount. I wasn't trying to say that the Western Wall isn't isn't
an important monument. I was saying the most important. I'm pretty
sure the most important is on top of the Temple Mount, not vaguely
placed around the foundation of the Temple Mount. You know what
I'm saying? >> That's on my on my streaming journey. Yeah,
good luck with your with your with your streaming. Load up your
PS5 and your NBA 9K or whatever you guys are playing now, and
yeah. I feel I feel a little bit intimidated that you have I
saw a line you have Frank Fukuyama after me later today. So,
you're you're elevating the intellectual game a little bit. Yeah,
something like that, yeah. Actually no, we're going to go over
the videos of Hasan shocking his dog for about an hour and a
half. I really want his perspective on the type of shock collar
I think he was using,
Dude, there's no way he's doing this whole minstrel show for
Tim. I don't really hate Hasan that much, Tim. You know, Hasan's
not that bad, Tim. I'm going to joke go joke around with Hasan
some more haha cuz that's all I do, right? Haha. That that's
silly. That would be silly to pretend that. That'd be silly to
pretend that all I do is talk about Hasan.
I don't. I talk about other stuff all the time. All right, bro.
I appreciate it. Holler at me anytime, okay? Yeah, thanks a lot.
Good luck. Okay, I've been told that I need to watch a little
bit of the follow-up, that the follow-up is very funny. He did
actually do that? Yeah, he did. No, he totally fell back from
everything. He fell back from all of the things.
He totally knelt. He declared Hasan the
Congratulations, Hasan. I
I didn't think he was I'll be real, I didn't think he was capable
of kneeling like this. I thought that was his whole thing. Right?
If he was capable of kneeling like this, why didn't he just settle
with Pixie?
You know what I'm saying? Like if he is ca- if he if it wasn't
about principle and he was just ready to kneel like this, why
did he spend all that money in the lawsuit? I thought he was
the guy who stood on principle.
Wait, what is that? Oh, it's only got 2,000 likes.
this one? Neoconservative political consultant Sarah Longwell
has been calling out Hasan [__] as too controversial
for the Democratic big ten, but she's been seen actively boosting
Steven Destinabonnel on X, a streamer with a far more troubling
record.
Yes, obviously true. In two recent reposts, Longwell retweeted
and amplified Destiny attacking Hasan and promoting his argument
that Democrats
abandon their progressive base for more moderate and electable
candidates. The irony is hard to miss. Hasan's controversies
are largely
He started doing the voice. He didn't like where it was going,
he started doing the voice. Oh, [__] I wasn't indicating
to you guys that this person is clearly wrong. Hold on, hold
on. >> torkal statement seen as offensive that he partially
walked back. Destiny's run deeper. He faces an active federal
lawsuit over allegedly sharing an explicit video of a woman without
her consent. Leaked chat logs allegedly show him in a I mean,
no, he he definitely did that. That's the funny part. That's
not what's alleged. The only real factual dispute here is whether
or not he spread it to other people and whether or not he spread
it like after the date that the law came into effect. The factual
dispute isn't on whether or not he spread the video without her
consent. It's not. conversation with a 17-year-old when he was
33. He also mocked Corey Campatora, the man who was shot and
killed at a Trump rally, calling me on live stream. Destiny also
admitted to choking a woman. God damn! I had to effing choke
her out a few times. That [__] got crazy. Hell yeah,
I did. I guarantee that everybody here probably thinks I'm a
crazy [__] too. Destiny has also been more embedded
in Democratic politics than Hasan. Canvassing for candidates,
interviewing sitting congressman, and actively campaigning. Hasan
[__] remember the remember the thing, pivot personal
attacks as much as possible. Always pivot, always personal attacks,
never fight on substance.
I did That's Why is it bad for people to do personal attacks?
There's He swaps up so much. You always do personal attacks.
But didn't he just call this guy
Hasan? Is it Is it the brotheler? He called him the brotheler
or something?
Jesus. Jesus Christ. Hasan [__] is a progressive
streamer who has been heavily critical of Israel and endorsed
Zohran Mamdani for New York City mayor. Oh my god. On the other
hand, Destiny has been a staunch >> I would love to know
from Mr. Mouton, does Mr. Mouton think Destiny didn't spread
that video without Pixie's
I would love for like a solid position there to come out from
Mr. Mouton.
He He knows that Destiny did spread the video without consent,
right? And that's obviously true considering he knew the
18-year-old sex worker for less than a week, but sorry, around
a week before he sent the video?
Like there's no way to believe at all from even his own story
that that person would have wanted that that Pixie would have
wanted that. There's just no way. There's no way to make that
even with his arguments. I wonder what Mr. Mouton thinks on that
front. defender of Israel, an attack dog, an attack dog against
progressives and Israel critics who endorsed Joe Biden over Bernie
Sanders in the 2020 primary. Didn't I I don't know if I formally
endorse, but I I preferred Zoran over anybody else over Cuomo,
I'm pretty sure. At the very least I know I supported him for
the general 1 trillion percent.
Uh Longwell has never publicly taken issue with Longwell has
never publicly taken issue with Destiny being part of the Democratic
big tent and it's now amplifying him because he retweeted me
I we I've never spoken to this person in my life before. I don't
know if I formally endorse, but I I preferred Zoran over anybody
else over Cuomo, I'm pretty sure. At the very least I know I
supported him for the general 1 trillion
Uh Longwell has never publicly taken issue with Longwell has
never publicly taken issue with Destiny being part of the Democratic
big tent and it's now amplifying him because he retweeted me
I we I've never spoken to this person in my life before. Longwell
asking, "What's the context for America deserve 9/11?" Well,
someone is reposting the account of someone facing a federal
harassment lawsuit. So, what do these two things have to What
is a policy ideological position and the other is at what Dude,
I just I can't imagine I can't believe that this is what's happening.
That he's sitting here going like, "Why would you ever bring
something up unrelated? Hasan the brothel or piker."
It's It's actually kind of wild. Destiny, thank you very much
for the primer. Appreciate it, man. worst personal failing or
whatever. At what what Unless he thinks I'm pro rape or harassment
as a point of policy.
Unless she sees that clip from yesterday and then she might get
the wrong idea. He's just
Republicans and Democrats both attacking Hasan makes things very
I'm sorry, I've never I've never propagated that one, so listen.
It's very funny. >> Clear. They hate anyone challenging
the established status quo, mainly hipsters. Republicans don't
attack Hasan ever. They just use him to make Democrats look
A total lie, totally
totally incoherent, doesn't make any sense, completely cuts against
reality, the whole Cuba thing that just happened. But I don't
I don't think Destiny really does politics very much anymore,
right? >> Hasan has never been deplatformed off of anything
in his entire life. He's gotten banned from Twitch like 20 times
for one
Never been deplatformed.
You
You literally
Dude, why is he pretending that it's everybody he's been persecuted?
Guys, he's been persecuted. He got demonetized
Dude, YouTube swept for this guy. His channel with those comments
he's making, that's an easy termination for most people. He got
so lucky that he just lost his monetization only.
day each. He's never been demonetized. He's had favorable exclusive
contracts with Twitch above even what average top-tier partners
get. He's never been banned on any YouTube thing. He's got his
own media or his own merch that he pays to advertise on.
Destiny got banned after the Charlie Kirk thing saying, "Oh,
good. Conservatives should be a little bit scared right now."
Okay, that's what he got Sorry, demonetized for, okay? What did
Hasan do when Charlie Kirk got shot? Didn't Hasan cry? exclusive
contracts with Twitch above even what average top-tier partners
get. Uh-oh. >> In 2021 and 2022, Sarah Longwell, 25's firm,
made $950,000 each year from the Koch network.
What's the beef between these two? Are you talking about me,
Sharky girl? Um the guy who's on the stream right now went and
argued that you should like do whatever to people in my community.
You should dox people in my community. Supported Destiny doxing
people in my
And I just genuinely don't appreciate that. I've never done anything
like that to them. It's not supported by my community, not supported
by my by my Discord in any way. Um but they like to make up this
lie completely. So, unlucky. According to Stand Together's tax
filings, this is who is telling Democrats what streams they should
and shouldn't go on. If you were cashing Koch checks in 2022,
I don't think you have standing to nitpick a streamer's comments
from like a decade ago. He's so bad Oh my god, bro. Holy [__]
These comments are from like either A this year
What? The you talked about America deserving 9/11 multiple times
here. You literally highlighted in that Instagram post and talked
about it. When when do you think that clip was? By the way, was
that clip before or after Destiny and him were friends? Were
they friends after that? Or were they friends before only before
that? I actually don't know. 9/11 was from 2019, so 7 years ago.
That's got to be Destiny agreed with the sentiment even after
they were enemies. Well, you hate to see it. Okay, I just want
to see how this tweet came about now. Now the guy says this is
the This is the tweet where Ryan Grim points out the obvious.
Okay, Destiny comes back and goes, "Her made 950K each year."
Mate, it's a 501c3 nonprofit. They aren't making money.
What was her involvement with this? Her
I Hold on.
Why is he not just What is he reading? Go to this.
Compensation 950. Longwell Partners Inc. Look for a Longwell
Partners Inc. Her name is Sarah Longwell.
What What are we doing?
This is a C3. Wait, her firm made 950K.
This is a This is a C3. This is a
Wait, isn't this the financial for the 501c3? I don't even know
if they Yeah, this is the financial filing for the 501c3 where
they're paying it out.
He just Dude, Taylor Lorenz got to dance on this guy's grave,
right? This is obviously what he's clicking on is the financial
output from the Koch brothers like 501c3
to her thing, right? No? >> when he said this, my assumption
is they were making like money doing it, but this is a nonprofit.
So, this all had to be paid out. I don't even like the way he
the way he phrased seems bad faith. Am I missing something? Are
there other types of C3s I can take a profit? Wait, he doesn't
understand that this is the C3 that paid? Am I Dude, I maybe
I'm crazy cuz I don't I truly don't I always want to say in my
head like I don't think Destiny's a complete [__]
right? I I because I swear like it's really embarrassing that
I ever thought he was a compelling creator if he's this dumb,
but this would be the Koch brothers thing, yeah? And then if
you like look on this, you'd see Longwell partners and see $950,000
paid out to them.
By the way, Ryan Grim's thing does not do a good job of explaining
this.
So, Destiny looked at this after he's been constantly chastising
Taylor Lorenz directly. He looked at this right here, this tweet,
and he decided to come back at Ryan Grim and go, "Dude, mate,
it's a 501c3 nonprofit. They aren't making money."
He actually has no idea what he's talking about. The only way
he was able to critique Taylor Lorenz is because somebody else
explained to him what to argue. He is an actual functional
This is so embarrassing to have this to to tweet this out and
not understand what you're looking at here at all within weeks
of trying to call Taylor Lorenz a [__] who doesn't
know anything, who doesn't even know how these forms work. You
don't even know what any of these forms are.
Dude, that's crazy.
That's crazy.
Or I This seems obvious to me.
Maybe the obvious thing is wrong, though. I don't think so. I'm
pretty sure it's not.
Oh, that's rough, dude. That is so rough. Oh, I'm glad I watched
a little bit more. How long will it take him to find out? He's
been looking at it for a while. How long will it take him to
find out? >> received any charitable contributions
any Also, when you say related to the Koch brothers, don't the
Koch brothers have their hands in like almost
They're huge Republican donors, yeah. >> They are, but
they I they have like so many different like interconnected orgs
and everything else. Dude, there has to be somebody in the chat
who's pointing out There's some There has to be somebody in the
chat who is pointing out what's going on here, right? Like it's
been It's been minutes of this now. How do you not There's no
way There's no way there's this many people who are totally incapable
of looking at this and understanding what's going on, right?
>> is a nonprofit.
I'm sorry, when he said this my assumption is they were making
like >> get the chat now. I was doing it, but this is a
nonprofit. So this all had to be paid out. I don't even like
the way he the way he phrased this seems bad faith. Am I missing
something? Are there other types of C3s that can take a profit?
Or is he just mad that they received any charitable contributions
any Also, when you say related to the Koch brothers, don't the
Koch brothers have their hands in like all
Nobody's pointing it out. almost everything >> Nobody's
pointing it out. They're huge Republican donors, yeah. They are,
but they I they have like so many different like interconnected
orgs and everything else. Just when I think this whole like movement
that Destiny's got going can't be any dumber,
they've fallen they've lowered the bar
This is I I'm sorry, you you
You guys understand what's going on here, right? Oh, thank god.
Oh, thank god. Somebody Somebody Somebody came along and went
Look at the schedule, B.
Holy Thank god somebody finally came along and told this guy
how to get unstunlocked.
Holy [__] Holy [__] That took a long
time. >> Seemed like you and Tim pretty much agreed on
most things. Um kind of. I'm a lot further along, but it was
a gentle conversation on planting
He wasn't for our idea of uh you have to be under oath. What
a fool.
I mean he was kind of there. He just said to be you'd have to
prior to work >> there soon. Dude, this is so [__]
This is going to get clipped to [__]
Just as an aside, when he to crowd Ryan Grim started >> Oh,
right. He literally can't figure it out because if he'd figured
it out at any point here, I'm silly now. If he'd figured it out
at any point here, he wouldn't have tweeted at Ryan Grim, right?
And tried to point out that he was wrong. So, he actually doesn't
figure it out despite the chat explaining how to go and look
for what he's looking for. He actually just going to continue
to be wrong until he tweets at Ryan Grim.